ah
[Music]
i connected with you from the second i
see in your first audition
yeah yeah and i was watching that yeah
2012. i'm james arthur
james arthur you have a voice that has
pain in it
i had a lot of unresolved childhood
trauma going into that whole process
i ended up in foster care at the age of
like 13 14. they gave me a lot of volume
and got me through the rest of the show
and and antidepressants one of i was so
medicated
from week two onwards i look back at
that and i'm like how the [__] did i win
that show
the winner of the x factor the gentleman
that is mr
james arthur i did everything i could
once i got there
to [__] it off basically i don't like
this the pressure the anxiety
i was having panic attacks eight times a
day calling ambulances like
[__] felt like i was everything about
my being i was just
uncomfortable in my skin talking about x
factor james arthur 2.5
million copies that first singles
best-selling x-factor uh single ever
i remember my manager coming in and
being like so the label aren't going to
take up the next
option with you they're not going to do
the next album i was like what do you
mean they don't want to be associated
with you because of your behavior and
stuff like that i remember my heart
sinking
part of me was like ah [__] this really
is over now and then the other part of
me is like
well you wanted this like you did
everything you could to make sure that
you pushed all this i pushed everyone
away i pushed all my family away my
friends
i just was just so acting so crazy that
began two
two and a half years of just severe
depression that i was like 200 300 grand
in debt
and everything was resting on whether or
not i could write this album and i wrote
say you won't let go
it went to number one in the charts i
got a call from psycho asking me to come
back to them they wanted to resign me
they wanted me to come back on x factor
and perform all of that [__] happened on
the same day and i was just like
what the [__] it was like a dream that
[__] little
three and a half minute song that i sat
down and wrote
brought me back from the dead like
i think the kickoff's quality and i
watched um sorry i forget the name of
your co-host that you're with
um oh lauren sorry i saw that thing
where he's kind of like
[Music]
i think you were saying you were
struggling for funding for a little bit
on on it and then the twitch thing
happened and like you were a bit
emotional about it
oh and i thought that was cool i i love
it it's nice seeing a bunch of
lads just sitting around talking about
football and the production value of
your podcast is
is well that's probably why better than
everyone else's
that's why i was struggling i mean it's
definitely better just yeah but i was
you know yeah um you know what it's like
coming from nothing so when you get
yourself to a point and then you feel
like you're going to lose it all yeah
freaking out what's up
yeah he's a bit on an angle there can we
make them as central as possible
can you make me look handsome yeah
thanks we'll edit that there's a lot of
editing going to be required
[Music]
all right if you're happy with that i'm
happy with that you go as far as you can
but i mean um yeah it was touch and go
because we had to
yeah i i was basically in debt because i
was not paying my taxes in order to
[__]
fund this yeah and it was like okay some
point is going to work out so that when
it happened i was like
[__] everything yeah yeah yeah i'm
really glad for you
i yeah i find myself watching
a lot of sort of i found myself watching
you know mark goldbridge
oh yeah yeah i found myself in wormholes
just watching you know
it's [__] mental right because robbie
williams message is the exact same thing
and i'm like
like it's so weird when you don't know
who the [__] watching you as a
youtuber yeah as a music artist yeah i
feel like you guys
click up and you kind of you know i look
on
your post and i see other artists
talking to you and saying i love the
whereas celebrities are secretly
watching youtube yeah we're unaware of
it yeah
we're all synonymous with each other i
think we're we all yeah i'm i'm such a
big sports fan like so it's
again yeah you're a massive fight fund
as well big fight fan yeah i love ufc
i think i've watched i'm a bit of a nerd
with it i've watched every event
probably for the last
ten obviously even longer ten years or
something like that plus yeah what was
your like
original era that you started the era
that i started watching it was probably
like
uh the frank mia brock lesnar sort of
yeah we had frank mia on the podcast did
you really i [__] you know i've not seen
that one i shook his hand
and i'm a we're big lads right you're
about the same size as me
i [__] shot his hand i thought i've
never felt like hands
like shovels emasculated yeah me i was
like this guy could just bend me i'm
saying something if you feel emasculated
by me i was just like
you please don't [__] me yeah like you
know what i mean
like he could do anything he wanted this
guy but he was sound
he was sound as [__] well that was back
when we were in the [__] studio like
bless him
and he was telling us some mad stories
that i can't even repeat right i can
imagine yeah
trained killers aren't it's just it's
mad to me i i train with the guys he's
like a featherweight
guy called richie and even hey i'm much
bigger than him but you just know like
if he wants to have his way with me just
you know what what you're thinking about
the ufc right now who who are you
impressed by at the minute
who am i impressed by the minute um i'm
disappointed not to have seen that
zabeet fight a bit more because he was
looking like the guy that was
the most complete fight adasana is
probably he's probably the guy
i love watching other songs he could be
the sort of second coming of
jon jones what i love about him is he
he's winning in spectacular fashion
but he's defending the title like
anderson used to you can rely on him
it's not like
18 months ago but like the john jones
you wouldn't see him for ages and
obviously after his prime
yeah the police [__] started and then
connor he
once they hit superstar yeah they they
lose they sort of disappear a bit don't
yeah you called out romero
like who who who called it he didn't
need to fight him i think he was he was
a little bit down the pecking order at
that point yeah i like people who like
go after people like that exactly yeah
nice quality um but i watched the last
um
the last one with um the welterweight
belt and i genuinely think um
kamaru uzman who's unstoppable he's like
some very well-rounded he's got a chin i
think that's probably his best ass i
think i saw
your analysis of that and just i think
you said like
maybe his best asset is the fact that he
can take a shot because once
you know once he got past burns's first
the big shots that he took off him he
kind of like it was just sort of he just
stays right in front of him
you'd you'd [__] with someone's head
because when you get
like get someone like that and they're
just still there that's the thing it's
going to drain the confidence yeah
i watched uzman woodley live and i
watched that happen i watched woodley
the the life drainer or woodley as he
sort of everything he tried everything
he could and he just
i think he beats prime gsp i i genuinely
do because jsp was an amazing wrestler
but when he got hit
yeah he'd shy away a little bit of the
wrestling but with
guzman you can't really just go to the
wrestling and i think uzman would just
out man him yeah like in every
department um
but hi welcome to the welcome yeah here
we are we could talk about this for
hours i knew i'd get you on monday not
just because we started talking
probably about a couple of year ago i
first started messaging you a little bit
but
also when i started the podcast you were
on my list because i thought
northern lad yeah covered in tattoos we
don't really make a success of ourselves
i thought we're going to cross paths at
some point because there's not many
lads like you out there and from day one
i'm not just saying this either
i connected with you from the second i
see in your first audition
yeah yeah and i was watching that yeah
2012. well i was like who's this kid
and you know from the north and i think
the audition was in newcastle
yeah you have a voice that has
pain in it and i was like because
there's someone who a
bit of a troubled soul type feel like
when someone can
can put that into music yeah yeah as
a we don't really have man singers
right you sing like a man things right
do you know what the elvis song like
amman sings yeah
like you mean like that working class
like northern south yeah but a great in
it
like it's as a because no offense i'm
not listening to justin bieber i'm
pretty sure he's not watching so it's
fine
but you know if you are [__] nice i'm
talking you come on
but yeah yeah please come on you speak
yeah you speak to
you can speak you can sing the women but
as a man
it's a type of you know even when you do
a love song i can be like yeah i can
feel where you're coming from
yeah and um i haven't actually set this
podcast up well at all we're supposed to
say thanks to
chance the gym shock uh by the way shout
out to the sponsors and also
lawrence who would normally be here is
working on something else that's why
he's not here he hates god that's fine
he's actually he's a fan though but um
he's working on some excellent video
that the people are going to love but um
cool yeah i've always liked you mate and
um
and it's great to finally get you on
because um
it kind of funny how this came about
because you
uh were gonna come on and we never got
round away and then
you obviously had some time off and you
were doing your thing
and one of the things that you messaged
me after originally was when you
had beef with youtubers and you were
like bro what the [__] is this all about
and i'm like oh
i gotta give you some some tutorials on
how to handle this in the future
yeah that was about a year ago now
that's right yeah um
yeah uh it was the sidemen that you sort
of went back and forth with and then you
sort of were like okay i'm done with
this
what what sparked all of that off in
your head
i was i was wondering whether we were
going to talk about this i think it's
good to get out there yeah because
you've had
this is my audience yeah and that's kind
of what i did and after talking to you
one-on-one yeah yeah i'm like
that is not you no no and yeah for
respect i i was saying this on the
journey over i was like i wonder whether
he wants to talk about this because for
sure this is your world it's your domain
and um the people that they kind of be
honest i think a lot of them think
you're a bit of a dick for the way that
went down absolutely i could see and i
can see
why um i don't think i've ever come
across well
on social media like i think that's just
i think it's hard to be honest i just i
haven't nailed that side of things like
as long as i'm putting out music that's
of a high quality and
um you know and things in that world um
then i think i think people people
resonate with that and that's what they
want from me and that's all good
and there's one reason why i've done
this because uh and it's and
this is the first time i've done
something like this to be fair a long
form interview which is where i think
people will get to know me better
um it's hard though isn't it because
you're trying 140 characters
and i don't even tweet like that you
know why yeah because people can like
choose their own tone of voice yeah yeah
for your words i don't
stop putting opinions out this is watch
my videos because they're so
manipulatable but
how so how i remember it because i did a
bit of research last night looking back
at it yeah i was thinking what [__]
happened there
and one of the lads tweeted out
um my mates got a song with rick ross
yeah yeah and you
responded and looking back at it i'm
like why do you kid
and you were like only because he paid
money for it or whatever and i'm like
yeah james offer though yeah okay so so
this this is the thing and do you know
what
um let me preface this by um
by saying um i watched one of these guys
i don't know if he's actually part of
the seidman and by the way
i don't pay much mind to this that much
these days i in actual fact in in
hindsight looking back on that whole
thing um you know i have nothing but
respect for these people
um you know that do youtube like those
like sidemen are somewhat pioneered a
sort of space within youtube and
i get i don't get all of it it's not
some of it's not gonna be my thing and
um
you know what but fair play at the mall
but one of the lads i think he's called
cal freeze or something
like i think he was on another he was on
another podcast
almost kind of celebrating the idea that
some of the things that some of the
personal things that they'd said
during that whole spot had like got me
off of social media like they were it
was kind of like
yeah we officially got them off social
media which i thought was
a little bit in poor taste and like you
know i think some of the things they
said appeal to the nature of the kind of
like sort of hate culture
and and like trolling culture on on
twitter especially
um and yeah like i don't want to start
up some kind of thing
in a healthy way rather than yeah going
about the wrong way so if i can try and
guide you across
how i seen it and yeah yeah when you
went at them
first yeah yeah looking out as a guy who
kind and knows you but doesn't know you
well yeah yeah and i know them fairly
well i spent a good amount of time with
them
i felt like the minute you opened that
door i thought oh
yeah because they never i think at a
point after that you were kind of
responding
they are just going to banter you no
matter what happens yeah and i don't
know if hate culture is the right word
but
i think their their form of humor yeah
is to just take nothing you say
seriously yeah yeah
and use you for laughs and that's my
humor as well to be fair that's how it
started i mean you could say that
what i said was banter like i i
basically
and the one thing that cal faris did say
that was correct on the podcast he was
doing was like
you know a lot of these artists are
sitting around in hotel rooms all day
when they're on tour and
you know it's probably late and he's
winding people up on twitter and
then there's an element of truth to that
you know we we all do we sit around like
no i'm in germany in a hotel room at
this point three o'clock in the morning
probably shitless probably might be half
pissed whatever i don't know
i can't really remember where i was um
but
i've i've had a habit of doing that over
the years like you know having a bit of
crack on online and it not coming across
right so
i'm in the music industry so i know what
it costs for rick ross a rick ross or or
a thai dollar sign or something like
that because i'm because i'm in the
business
this is my field and and and the crack i
was having was like
this kid's like bragging about you know
i it's me being
having a rick ross and i i thought it
was funny to say yeah but it'd cost you
50k
like to have to have him on the track
which to me is just
a bit of crack really and then he came
back with like some meme about me being
sully and i was like
i'm not why would i be jealous i mean i
get their youtubers and all that and
they get views and stuff but
um i'm it's not it's not a jealousy
thing like
i think one of my videos is probably
more views and
the whole lot put together that they've
ever done so it's not as if i'm like
after their audience or
or clout from that kind of um that
those sorts of fans or anything it was
it just started a bit of crack and it
got out handed
i think i think if i'm honest with you
just i've got to be i want to take this
completely honestly and i you know
last thing i was a [__] uh a guest
walking out in five minutes like
that's right i think they were
completely being silly
yeah yeah and i think at some point you
went
and maybe this is four in the morning
you've had a few extra drinks so you're
like
i'll slap the head off you well that's
because well that's because like i mean
you know
where where i come from where you
similar where you come from when you
start talking about people's dead
relatives and like
you know when you start calling people
crackheads and i get like that's
that's that's in front of you is that
what they said
one of them said like shaggy dead nana
or something oh this is one of the side
men i think his name's harry or
something
he's cracking he's a young lad and you
know we have daft i have silly crack on
my mates in person that's
maybe across the line but when you do
that and personally i know fine well
that kid's not going to say that to me
in person if he sees me probably
going to be quite nice to me there are
nice lads for the record i'm sure they
are i think once
you start once you start talking about
my dead relatives or
you start like saying things that kids
can run with
and i've never done crack in my life by
the way so to call me a crackhead
[Music]
i don't feel walking around saying that
[__] so i'm like so i dm'd them it
wasn't as if it was just this i was like
hang on
we're now getting into fight talking
you're like this is this is a territory
where
if you said out to my face we're
fighting you know what i mean so
i was wound up they did they did get me
wound up
and they're very good at that and that's
that's why i'm so am i but like
you call that good banter and good crack
to me it got to the point where it
wasn't it was just like
there was nothing really funny about it
it was just it was making
it was like if it was making those kids
think it's all right to say those things
to people to me that was that was the
the line it was crossing and this is
it's kind of an intro for you into
the new the new way this online culture
has gone me
because i've had you know early on
i was a bit like well you're saying like
yeah anyone says this i'm a [__]
knockout yeah that's just
that's just yeah because you come from a
working-class northern place just like
me
but to to the to the new generation
yeah it's just a laugh it's it's and the
minute you take anything seriously
yeah and i know you've lost you know i
know this like i've been around the game
long enough i know and
i've been embroiled in many twitter
spotlight you know
i've learned my lesson from from those
kinds of things but
with them i just like it just i think it
just got out of hand and um
and like i said i think some of the
things they said appeal to the nature of
people that
that think it's okay to say certain
things and and and at that point in time
i just felt like i wanted to stand up to
it a little bit and and i went about it
the wrong way
i got too angry about it and that's why
i stepped away and because someone
told me to shag my dead nano this is
weird that people are liking this like
it just i
like you said i had to sort of step back
and think i need to navigate this in a
different way because
it's not yeah that's that's what i found
interesting is when you put the tweet
out going
i'm handing this over to the management
i thought yeah that's not the first time
you've said that as well
yeah yeah yeah and i thought myself um
why does this keep happening yeah why do
you think it keeps happening out of
interest why do i think it keeps
happening um i mean
it's happened a couple of times i think
it's because i i have um
i have a tendency to probably get myself
in in the spots in my life where i'm
where i'm a little bit unhappy
and maybe i'm tired or maybe maybe i was
overworked um
it's interesting you'd say unhappy
though because yeah a lot of people
when they're feeling a certain thing
about their life or themselves or
whatever and then something pisses them
off and then they say something
yeah it is quite normal for that to come
out in the way
yeah i mean i'm just i think i'm just
like i'm a human being i didn't do it
you know and um
and i've never wanted to be that sort of
like
you know i came through the x factor and
all that and i think some people
confused that whole thing as you're
being manufactured in some way and like
you've been turning into this
well i think they are they're just it's
just you're one of the exceptions i'm
just not that
and and i never wanted i never i refused
media training i never wanted to be that
shiny
pop star i mean i'm not look at me i'm
just not that guy i'm just and
and i think maybe that's why i've made
those decisions sometimes because i'm
like
maybe like ed sheeran or uh sean mendes
probably would never reply at this point
but i i
them are i i'm a different sort of cat
and maybe like
like it feels it feels more real to me
to to
to respond sometimes i guess or to say
something
say enough um i appreciate the honesty
yeah that's um that's just
my for the record knowing the lads yeah
and knowing you to the degree i do yeah
i think you'd actually have a right
laugh with him i'm sure i would i'm sure
and again
i think the way i look at it looking
back at it is
when you when so one of them was
bragging about what ksi had achieved
yeah yeah
ksi is responsible for a lot of people
being successful
exactly and partly me included he's
helped me out over the years as well
and i'll always be grateful for the lad
so when you
when you come at the king he doesn't
everyone will
defend him to the [__] hilt right and
then the fans on top of it so
i think that was that was it like and um
you know fair play you got rick ross on
his song absolutely yeah
actually it wasn't as if i was saying
he's not good enough to have rick ross
on the song i was just saying like
what do you make of his success ksi
because he's actually
the second best-selling new artist last
year or something like that in the uk
and but he's a youtuber and yeah there's
no doubting
if he hadn't have come through youtube
he would not have craig david and rick
ross on his songs and all of the other
people he's hired but
you know because you came through a i
guess youtube is the new
x factor almost it's the new shortcut
yeah yeah how do you view
the youtube avenue of getting success um
well ksi particularly i can see
a level of talent there and um with the
music and
you know him taking on um
public like getting in a boxing ring for
a start you know being a
[__] being a fight fan pretty much my
whole life i
you know i know uh i mean anyone who
who's prepared to step into a ring
at all let alone in front of millions of
people
logan's a big lad as well i've met him
yeah yeah he looks like a big lady
he's about yeah from full respect i mean
and um like you don't have hit songs
just based on the fact that you're
popular
he's obviously got some talent there so
yeah i get it with care so i didn't know
a lot about him until this little
thing and again since that whole thing
um naturally i sort of
did my research and looked into it and
understood the whole thing i watched
interviews that you've done with him and
stuff and
yeah i get it with ksi not you know not
so much with some of the other cats but
like him i get it okay um
do you know before we get this can i get
a bit of water of course i realize my
mouth is dry
that [__] happened yeah yeah that was
that was sorry i didn't
i got it's a bit heavy getting into all
that youtube so i'm glad we i'm glad we
did it
yeah i think you've i think you've
cleared it nicely yeah yeah you know
what i mean i hope
i just didn't want i don't want to like
open up that whole thing again because
no no it's like a positive place in my
life right now and
i appreciate you don't want a wave of
[__] like that because i've had it
myself
yeah no look i mean i mean i've
within the first two years i was about i
got cancelled like no one's business i
had
i had the one direction fans me you took
the sidemen fans on in one direction
[Music]
you know that's some like they've really
cancelled cancel me for saying
some yeah i said some irresponsible i've
said a lot of irresponsible things and
what about the one direction thing then
because you mentioned that
and and you know you you really know how
to pick their fans to pick i mean i
remember
in my head looking back at it i remember
thinking if i'm your record label i'm
thinking yeah
what the like you this is the fun
group that we're hoping will be your
fans as well yep and you're basically
going yeah nah don't buy my rent
and and did some of those lads even
encouraged the fans to
vote for me when i was on the show so it
was like um do you know what it was me i
was just pressing the self-destruction
the self-destruct button uh like you
wouldn't believe i think i had a lot of
unresolved
we took we we started talking about
mental health and this this is maybe the
perfect segue because
because like um i had a lot of
unresolved
childhood trauma going into that whole
process i was i came from
i really came from obscurity having abs
i had nothing
i've lived in a little bed probably the
size of that bathroom you've got through
there
and um and you know lived in a building
full of drug dealers and ex-convicts and
um
you know and then maybe that's where
that yeah i'm all right i'm all right
maybe that's where that little bit of
defensiveness and that little bit of
like chip on my shoulder comes from and
when people come at me like it's my
natural
reaction to be like you know that's just
where that's just i think that's my
question
i [__] get it honestly and yeah
you'll get it and um
and so like where did it where do you
feel like that
that knowing something was you were
struggling with your mind
yeah can you remember when that began
even
yeah i mean it came from being young and
i think you know
parent the typical parents getting
divorced and
um i ended up in foster care uh
at the age of like 13 14 like sort of
formative years in my life i ended up
being in foster care and hiding all of
that from
my school friend so i was i was going to
school every day
and like then i was getting on the on a
bus on you know like waiting at the bus
stop on the other side of the road
to go somewhere and i didn't want to
tell anyone about it and that was a few
years of my life where i just felt like
kind of rejected by my family and my
parents and i think once you
have that you sort of like yeah it's a
hard one to shake i think you end up
with trust issues and things like that
and
well 100 because the people you're
supposed to trust the most in this world
are your parents it brought you into the
world so
you feel not wanted as much exactly and
and look i i've
they're forgiven for all that my mom's a
young mum four kids went through two
divorces a lot of stuff i i don't
blame her for all that and i wasn't an
easy kid um
but i think in answer to your question
when i went into this x factor process
and all of a sudden i'm one of the most
talked about people in britain
i'm like i won the x factor and i i got
the record deal and i'm
my job is to be a musician which is what
my dream that was my dream as a kid
and what i always thought would make me
happy and fulfill me when i got there
it's like what tyson fury says
like when when i won the world title i'm
like
what now oh so let you know what i mean
so it was kind of like
i did everything i could once i got
there to
[__] it off basically it was like what
can i do to get rid
like this i don't like this the pressure
the anxiety i was having panic attacks
eight
times a day calling ambulances like
[__] felt like i was
everything about my being i was just
uncomfortable in my skin
when you started the x factor journey
and you go on that stage
just to you know take it back to that
point yeah
you can see when you get on that on that
stage and i watched it over
yeah um not a lot of confidence and a
lot of
yeah there's a there's issues there and
you also did you did not look healthy
bro
but honestly you you guys started to
tell me you know what i mean
and you know you can see there's been
you you
openly admit there was a rift between
your mom and your dad and they'd come
together for that day and i think a lot
of people actually loved that bit of the
story to be fair
yeah because there's a lot of people out
there who have parents who separate and
don't speak and all of that
but we'll get into the x factor journey
in a bit but did anyone at any point
talk to you
about your mental health
on that show and are you coping okay and
are you ready
for this and try and help you along
because it's a [__] mental
because so like my journey for example
to being
well known was a lot slower yeah and a
lot more of a slow grind was as you say
you took off like a [__] rocket from
being
james in a bed sit with drug dealers to
all of a sudden britain's most talked
about singer
right yeah was there any any point in
that where they tried to sort of
is this kid all right is he ready for
this so we yeah are we looking after him
yeah i mean you know what the support on
the show was great i've got to be honest
um we had like welfare people around and
um
you know i don't i don't really think
there there's
um if you're someone like i was that
went into a process like that with all
of the demons that i had
um i don't think there's anything really
i mean i'm good at kidding on them all
right as well
i don't mean like i know what you mean
i'm just i'm you know i can pretend i'm
cool
fine's a good word doesn't it i'm fine
yeah i'm [__] yeah exactly we
like i'm [__] terrible i [__] hate
myself i don't want to die
but i'm fine i hate it but like it's a
you know i like when you talk about
being the sort of that
um archetypal bloke and like that so
we come from a culture that's quite much
the guys it's quite there's
a lot more cheese more if you like and
um
it's seen as a weakness to talk about
your feelings and emotions and to make
yourself vulnerable
and i think i had that probably had that
and that maybe got me through and maybe
made people around me think i was okay
but it wasn't until
there wasn't any support when i'd won
the show and i was in a flat in london
kind of by myself just sort of trying to
process the whole thing i'd been through
and there wasn't a welfare lady there
and there wasn't a doctor there
it wasn't until that point that it was
really a problem
i think i mean they got me through the
show to be honest uh like when i had
week two i had this big panic attack my
first ever like sort of
severe physical panic attack i've had
and um they just they gave me a lot of
volume and got me through the rest of
the show and
and antidepressants one of i was so
medicated
from week two onwards i look back at
that and i'm like
how the [__] did i win that show i was
probably at like
30 percent i was just like elvis was
great the one he saw
yeah he's the canary in the main if he
lasted as long as he did i kind of
missed them
a little bit you you actually look like
you gained a lot of weight as the show
went on
do you think the medication 100 percent
because you look at you on
obviously auditions you look like you
gained like three stones yeah i must
have i was gone it wasn't i was like
emaciated when i went on the show
that was just because i couldn't afford
to eat anything in a canteen food i was
like
let's go two breakfasts you know what i
mean i was sort of dug in
um yeah that was generally one of the
things it was like oh what i can
afford to have whatever i want to eat
now but i think the medication played a
part yeah 100
so going back to that first audition
then you come out
and um you did a version of a talisa
song was that a strategic thing
too it was present it was yeah i thought
it would i thought
in theory this is a good idea she's
having a hit with this song
and um and i just played around with
like an acoustic rap
version of it and it came off a treat
thankfully it was a
inspired decision yeah and you put like
yeah you put the wrap in and
one of the things that you made your
name for in doing
differently to any other contestant i
can remember
you know let's be honest x factor is
it's glorified karaoke
and and what what you did is show
creativity and actually
i can change your song around i can
write it differently i can make it sound
completely different
and you did that consist consistently
week after week after week
um what take me back to the feeling
of this is the first time in your life
that you're in a position to change your
life and the pressure is really on it's
like lose yourself moment yeah we
really got to pull this out and the
pressure's on
yeah going onto the stage belting it out
the reaction from the audience what was
that what was that actually like
can you remember it oh man yeah i i can
remember it vaguely
um that's a good question that's a
really good question like i've never
been asked to
describe that moment everyone's people
always ask me like was it like what's
life been like since the x factor or was
it like to win it
yeah i wasn't early in tears watching
that back right last night because i was
like
i feel like i'm from same place as you
and i know what it's like to feel like
you know this is your moment here you
have to be perfect
and you can change everything with this
one thing and just saying
you you actually turn around at the end
and you've got your hand over your face
yeah you can barely you know you can't
even
express your emotions you're like ruined
by you i couldn't i i remember i
couldn't even see at that point i
remember i remember just being like
just my i kind of glazed over but you're
right all of that stuff is at play all
of that chat is in your head this is
this is the chance this is
you know this is the moment um
this is my moment to change my life and
and then when you kind of like
if you you'll see i sort of take a a
deep breath
just before i do it i kind of said okay
i went okay to myself
like as if to say this is it there's
your are you
you're on the big stage you're on this x
you've got
barlow and all these shows in front of
you
and then um i just remember just laying
out there just kind of
like you know i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna
tuck my heart out there and see see what
happens and and then to sort of look up
and see a standing ovation
them all stood up and then to get the
comments like that i got it was just
um that's probably where the
severe anxiety began because i was just
like oh [__] it's gary baldwin's fault
yes oh no this this is like
this is mad like there's no expectation
on my shoulders i've lived this life of
like
you know no one ever really wanted
anything from me and all of a sudden
yeah
at the end of the song like you really
squeezed every last drop of
everything you had to give out i could
have yeah you've i felt it you know
yeah and um and gary barlow goes
i normally sit there and say change this
change out we've got to do this
for 99 of people but for you don't
change anything
yeah and yeah what was it like here on
that i was glad to hear that because
that's something that um
the x factor was never in my plans
really it was never something i wanted
it wasn't an avenue i ever wanted to
take because
um you know i looked up to people like
kurt cobain and these like
anti-establishment type figures and
um i wanted to be the front man of a
rock band um and that's that's sort of
what i was until that point it
it only happened because i was quite
frankly
bat [__] poor and desperate and my mum
bribed me into going and doing the
audition
itself um so to hear him someone like
that who who i'd regard as um
as a as an incredible songwriter and an
artist himself and
someone who's yeah just someone
definitely someone you to look up to
in the music industry to say something
like that it was cool it kind of
reaffirmed
[Music]
that um i can just be me and what i'm
what i'm doing and how
how i look and everything was fine which
i definitely i mean that was the
insecurity
for me it was like i didn't you know i'm
not justin bieber and that was that was
always the worry i have supreme
confidence in my ability i don't i don't
think anyone's on my level and
that's just the way i've always felt
like and that's what
the edge i think i've got over people is
because i just throw it out there
and and there's no holds bad kind of
thing um whereas
yeah it was the the the image thing and
you'll notice if i mean if you look back
the
me in the process i watch myself i
cringe i'm like there's no confidence
there in in
in until i'm on the stage and i'm
performing just
everything outside of that this i'm just
you can tell i'm just like
i'm worried that i'm being judged all
the time you know what i mean for my
personality
brutal way possible probably i would i'd
struggle with that if people were
judging
you know if i was a panel judging my
videos because it's my oh it's my it's
what i
feel like is my most the thing i've got
to give
true and it's a bit of a risk it takes
balls doesn't it but
you know yeah what point did you start
believing
you i'm gonna i could win this joe it
was the moment where um
so ella henderson and i think charmaine
were like the front runners for the
competition
um early on like a little bucky's
favorite or whatever
i was just happy to be there at first to
be honest and then um
i was in the ended up in the bottom two
with ella henderson
um who had been like the sweetheart the
favourite on the show
up until very talented super talented
she's still
still doing it to be fair she's heard in
ksi her in case
exactly yeah exactly yeah that was great
and yeah she's one of the very few
people from
any of these shows that are still
relevant doing stuff today
so like that's testament to her talent
but um
when i was in the bottom two were there
i was like well let's go it's curtains
for me this is this is
you know this is the end of the road for
me it's the same old story i'm not good
enough like all that stuff and
yeah definitely we had a sing-off and
yeah
when it went in my favor and it was at
that point that i started to ask
i remember i started like saying to
people i'm winning this now like this is
my competition now because she's
um she was unreal if you know if the
people like what i'm doing
this much then um i'm gonna i'm gonna do
my best to
to win the competition and and yeah that
was it i just sort of stepped up my game
at that point i think what was your um
actually your favorite song that you
sang just out of interest because
i had a few that i enjoyed yeah i like
the adele one that you flipped
yeah yeah uh hometown hometown glory
that was sick
and also you know the one i thought you
were really creative on was um
sexy and i know that's the one yeah i
was like that's like elvis that he's
like he's done like a modern day
elvis thing using yeah lmfao that that
that was probably yeah that'd probably
be the like if you're looking at
sort of um
performances that defined might define
my journey on x factor that would
probably be it i reckon because the
i i i enjoyed the chat i think the
premise of that show being that
you've got a like you said it's a
glorified karaoke competition and i
happen to agree with you like a lot of
people just go on and like
sing the songs well and so i think maybe
the reason why i
i did well on the show and i've done
well since is because like
i think you've got to take songs by
other people and
and take these themes you get these
themes thrown at you every week have a
week like
make another song seem like you wrote it
and i think there's a lot of work and a
lot of thought that goes into that and
you've got to interpret a song that no
one would
expect you to do and make it feel like
you
you wrote the song yeah and and and i
think the fact that i was able to do
that
week on week was why um i ended up
winning the show
like you know you look at some of the
other winners leona lewis for example
amazing singer don't get me wrong but
it's like just do your whitney
impression
like that's basically what they're
saying every week you know what i mean
like
she's amazing but it is that's what she
is isn't it like you know
phenomenal singing yeah as good as you
could yeah don't get me wrong but like
you changed it you know i mean i think
that you set a ball really high and i
know there was
some good winners after you who went on
to do well uh there was the
the girl group um that's the one sorry
i mean clearly a massive fight do you
know what i mean but they did well but
you know
it when it what was it like for you to
just say the show deteriorate
no i'm not i'm not being i don't know
this is a genuine question it obviously
you're getting nothing but true for me
yeah i'm not like i'm not here i'm not
but i'm not throwing like
i'm not trying to throw the show under
the bus it's just no it's it's
the way the world says i'm not like some
company man like protecting x factor or
anything like there was a platform that
gave
gave me everything you know and uh it
was a bigger show on tv you know
at one time it was a bigger show on tv
and i think like twitter
especially was at its peak and
everything
during the time i was on the show on one
direction and
those were i think maybe they were the
like golden years of x factor if you
like absolutely
um yeah i just i don't know maybe people
got
bored of the of the former and i think
it became a little bit predictable you
know with all due respect to the people
that make the show and some a lot of my
friends
made the show i think uh people got
bored of seeing that same kind of like
you know when you see the music and
stuff and the montages happen you know
this is going to be
the feature of the show and it all got a
bit predictable maybe
and uh yeah yeah i don't know maybe a
shortage of
of real artistry as well i don't know
one of the people obviously who you were
close with on the show
was nicole scherzinger i'm not jealous
at all
yeah what what what is she actually like
in person as just a real
regular friend oh it's a wonderful
person really just a
beautiful person um was it a bit hard
for you like looking at a woman that
because let's be real here yeah as
gorgeous as a woman can be
and you're a red-blooded male but she's
a mentor so there's this thing where
you're like
hmm i gotta think of you differently but
it's [__] hard this
yeah i mean obviously like very it was
always very intimidating being around
her at first especially like
because i'd only ever watched her like
when i was watching pussycat doll videos
you know just for the art of it
absolutely not nothing well
the great musicians everyone yeah what
there was thursday and the
what they're all grouping the harmonies
and all that like that's
that's that's why i tuned in no um no
yeah i mean
nicole really is an amazing musician oh
she can sing oh she's
she's a belter and um yeah you're right
yeah like
yeah you really feel like a piece of
[__]
when you're in the presence of something
that you know that amazing at first but
especially at that point of your life as
well because obviously
now if you schmooze them with [__]
celebs it's like all right i'm james
arthur
i belong here i feel a bit normal yeah
but back then
oh my god yeah it was even more like
what the hell is going on well
and like you know you'd have nicole was
just one of many people that were just
through the one minute robbie williams
was walking through the door gwen
stefani
now rogers like just these [__]
superstars that i'd only ever seen on
telly were just kicking about i mean
with nicole it eventually got really
natural because she's a very
down-to-earth
person and got me fully she got that i
was a bit of a tormented kid and
and all that and she she kind of
appealed to that nature and stuff and we
we're still really close-mixed
uh today so um
yeah but it's [__] like that whole
experience i went
you know we're talking about it now and
like i'm trying to recollect the whole
thing it was just
you know it's a cliche but it was a
whirlwind really well it was a short
period of time but it was one that
changed your entire life immediately
i remember there was one clip and
obviously as a lad i'm like
my guy you were talking to a aurora and
uh
rita was like performing that night
she's the actor
and you're like you're just looking like
one it's not even right how fit you are
it's just not even right she was like
blushing like shut up man and
you're like yeah i'm telling you i've
seen a couple of clips there was a bit
with caroline flack as well and that
i i did yeah i did fancy myself as a bit
of a smooth talker at times i just
just laid on the the pat are quite thick
and yeah the camera was rolling
sometimes
it's a bit cringy to look back at but
yeah
that's uh yeah that's that's another
moment i forgot completely forgot about
so you were assigned to um
simon cowell's record label yeah and
i was just wondering what he what is he
like because he comes across as the big
boss yeah
the whole [__] he owns so many artists
basically on his label
yeah yeah um what was the experience of
him like um
yeah so i never dealt with him
throughout the show obviously um
i spoke to him on the phone after i'd
won and
um he's got a bit of a i don't know how
to put it but he's kind of got like a
you know it's 20 21 i don't know how to
say this but he's got a feminine sound
to him right yeah like a pussycat like
he sounds a bit
do you know um if you watch um
queen's old interviews and you see
what's his name freddy yeah
hi darling oh yeah he's got a bit of a
sound to him like darling yeah i think
you know what i think that's quite i
think that's maybe just like a showbiz
culture thing yeah
there's a lot of people in in that
industry like you know
quite like very comfortable with the
sexuality and all that kind of stuff
and um yeah i think it's i think he's
just he's
he's classy comes from class he's used
to a high like you know
a kind of upper class lifestyle and
that's that's his vibe but he's very
down-to-earth as well
like the guy you see on the show you
know i'm sure there's an
element of him playing up to uh uh or in
the past anywhere
playing up to a sort of a villain type
thing yeah uh it made him
didn't they made him yeah and um but but
i was surprised to find someone when i
spoke to him in person it was just kind
of kicking back and
it's very cool and suggested really cool
things
in terms of like the creative stuff like
bespoke performances i was really
surprised and
and impressed by him as a as a creative
person i
i guess to be completely honest watching
the show over the years i found
the whole thing a little bit corny at
times absolutely and found what
you thought louis walsh doing halloween
like you shot there
yeah and like i guess i guess maybe i
laid some of the
i was like what's simon doing kind of
thing and then you know
you realize how tv's made and all this
kind of stuff and
so he was he was smart looking back at
it actually
his career started doing i think
wrestling music
yeah and and then obviously he featured
as a personality on a tv show
before he knows that he's got his own
show his own production company then
he's signing every artist off at the
back of that just many inspired
calls zig zag and these things he
apparently was like in loads of deaths
mate he was
bankrupt so that is a lesson right there
yeah for people out there feeling
especially at this point hopefully it's
like he come back
he come back as bad as anyone as good as
anyone oh man
i mean i've been at a couple of his
events where he's been honored and stuff
and um
i mean his stories but i think he moved
back in with his mum and dad at 35 like
no
coin like he's not i don't think he's
had it easy at all
um so to be where he is like you can
only tip your hat to him i suppose
so obviously you get to the point where
you're competing in the final yeah
you got to choose your song that you're
going to you sing do you
did you choose that or did they choose
it or do you get a few options as in the
winners singles
yeah yeah because uh no i had no no
choice in that i just had to figure it
out
really yeah yeah well they chose the
song impossible was um
was i don't know whether this is public
knowledge or if anyone would give a [__]
by the way but um
uh cher lloyd was going to do it if
she'd won uh do you not remember sherloy
yeah yeah i mean the saddest thing about
chair lloyd
someone who was watching the show that
he wrote is the thing she's now most
famous for
which one of you has had a [__] is it i
don't know about this yeah do you know
so there's a [__]
there's a yeah you know what i'm on
about where there's two girls
going i'm going to perform cherylide and
the two little scottish girls
and they're in the middle of doing their
little wrap right and the mother burst
through the door
and she goes which one is on a [__]
and they look at her terrified because
this mother is clearly bonkers
yeah disgusting oh they're disgusting
that's the one
that's the full clip but they were big
that's what she's known for now yeah
well i mean
i mean she might be doing something good
look there yeah hopefully she's making a
few bags from it but uh
yeah she could have copyrighted that she
your spotify thing would mean nothing me
yeah it would mean nothing compared to
that yeah
but yeah so you got the song picked what
a weird segment you got the song picked
for you right yeah yeah
you smashed that song thank you so
considering it wasn't picked for you
they did a good job did you grow it i
love it did you love it straight away
i hate it and do you know what a lot of
the time on the show like without
blowing my own trumpet like
songs gets you have like these a r
meetings um at the beginning of the week
where there's a bunch of like label
heads and
the the music department on the show
you get you all get in a room and go
should we do this song should we do that
song and
and then you kind of have to figure out
a lot of product the production of how
it's going to be and stuff and i guess
with a lot of contestants
they they probably had to do everything
for
the contestant because they didn't
really have a sense of identity or
anything
so it's like we're just going to make
you this track and you're going to sing
it
whereas i always like they once they
realized that i had a bit of now
in with you know how things should be
produced and well you're an actual
artist i had an idea of
how i want exactly yeah things that how
i wanted things to sound
um they let me kind of take control and
that's kind of how it happened with
impossible i was like yeah
the song is clearly a great tune but can
we do this with a production can we do
that and
same with the when i did hometown glory
and it went into a dubstep thing i was
like
dubstep's kicking off let's do that
let's let's somehow
let's somehow incorporate that into this
performance and it ended up being like
a thing that's still looked back on as
like a great moment on x factor i think
um so when you sing it now what does
that feel like
when i sing impossible now yeah do
something like i'll die inside every
time
now i'm sick of singing it obviously but
it's also like responsible for
um you know it's why a lot of people
know me around the globe i suppose um
so i'm very grateful to the song uh we
we did we've totally mixed switched it
up now if you come see one of my shows
it's like a rock thing now so
so you've made it more fun for yourself
i have to keep reinventing the song
otherwise it's just so destroying the
same way
[Music]
i love the fact that your fans are like
no they know this i'm so honest with
them i'm like it's like [__]
guantanamo bay [__]
i'm like seriously so okay so
that comes out number one yeah i think
it was like the biggest selling
x factor winner single ever at that
point something like that
and you you talked about this earlier
you're now
the winner on the one hand you're a kid
who's come from nothing had very little
confidence
but then on the other hand you're still
that kid who's got a chip on the
shoulder who won't be denied
um there's a bit of a battle going on
because the whole world is now telling
you
james you're amazing and you know you
you're only human
and i've tried to describe this to other
people before it's like
sometimes when everyone's telling you
[__] class yeah you kind of do feel
hey i'm pretty [__] good man like
yeah so what is the ego doing at this
point now you're the x factor winner are
you
are you in that battle of trying to be
down to earth or are you getting carried
away where is it at do you think it's a
really good question because i
i think i still grapple with that whole
thing
like i think i actually
credit my like mike tyson says a really
cool thing
um i'm sure you've heard him say this
because i'm sure you're a big fan being
a fight fan but he says something about
like
when people ask him if he's happy and
he's like what what what the [__] is
happiness like happiness is a fleeting
moment's um
like no one's happy 24 hours a day
without that um adversity
there's no progress without that
self-doubt you know without those
insecurities there's no progress and
i i think that me having that level of
insecurity and that that
self-deprecating
thing where i beat myself up all the
time has probably allowed me
to get as far as i have because i
haven't really let people
what people say about me go to my head
too much
which it's probably surprising to hear
having seen some of the [__] i've said
online
but that's just smacked off i get what
you're saying though but you know what i
mean it's like
um you're speaking to my [__] soul
yeah probably
totally get away it's it's exactly it's
exactly that it's like
i mean i i yeah i do have people telling
me i'm amazing all the time i do and
like
i resent i don't like it i don't i don't
really feel i don't really does it just
go over there
it's completely over my head now going
no i'm not i'm [__]
but then on but you we're just people so
on the flip side
yeah before you go out on stage you
you can flip the switch and go i'm
amazing that high high confidence that
you need to perform at that level
mix with that amazing self doubt that
you have in order to
create what you need to create yeah
they're two
extremes that are generating the output
100 and it's like watching
um a fighter in his prime mini that chip
on your shoulder
that self-doubt i want to prove everyone
wrong
you know i think that's why fighting
resonates with us so much
because it's so synonymous it's like
that moment where those guys get in
there
in their underwear in front of millions
of people and and click that
switch you know what i mean i can relate
to that because you know
it's the same really with getting on
stage in front of
thousands of people and and it's like
entertain us like
and you can't get up there and act like
you're not confident or you don't
believe in yourself or
you know because it won't be you know
people people are sussed out straight
away
um so there's definitely a i definitely
like
tread that line of you wrestle but yeah
yeah
definitely because one it's funny
because before conor mcgregor
fought i had a conversation with my
boxing trainer and he said mcgregor's
gonna lose
because um he's not insecure anymore i
thought the same thing
he's too comfortable in his life and
he's too happy with what
what has come of it yeah whereas when
you're
still that insecure person as you
have um managed to hold on to yeah which
is the burning fire of
feeling not good enough to put that work
in
it's it's a gift and a cursing on the
one hand because that's kind of
part of the mental health troubles yeah
where you never give yourself enough
credit and you're not content
yeah but it is the fire that provides
the artistry
isn't it it do you know what i mean
that's but that's a perfect way to put
it and i think that's why i've kept
hitting these
these roadblocks because i'm just living
this life of trying to strike that
balance it's like
i don't think i'm good enough don't
think anyone's i don't think i'm getting
enough credit for how much better i am
than everyone else or what i do
that doesn't make sense but it does make
sense to me yeah but to a
but i guess to a fan of yours yeah
they're going to be like what
what do you mean it's like yeah you know
for
x amount of hours in a day i can feel
like [__] yeah but then i can hear
another artist on the radio
and i go i'm better than him yeah i can
beat him yeah hang on a minute yeah hang
on a minute like
i've got those tools and i've got a lot
of other tools like why didn't i
why am i not being talked about like
i've pioneered some genre or whatever i
don't know it's just
i think i think with me as well i think
maybe there's a bit of a
there's a bit of a chip and i probably
shouldn't even talk like this on here
because it probably won't come across
very well but
like i do think i've got to work twice
as hard as everyone else because of
where i come from
and and and like mason and uh i feel
like
and it's like when you're working class
right this is a it's an unspoken
it's an unspoken prejudice because there
are far worse prejudices in the world
that are far more important to get to we
gotta get to those ones first
yeah but i for example see sky sports
and bt sport
picking um mr perfect
over myself yeah and i'd go with it with
it are we gonna ignore the fact that i
was
the one who did the commentator for
every single fight did all the podcasts
got the best out of the lads i even set
the [__] fight up you know
but no you're not interested in me
because what because of my attack
because of my time because i'm a
majority
accent yeah because i come from nothing
like you know what i mean like yeah
and at that point that's where the chip
grows and it's not about
being jealous of other people yeah it's
about knowing
what your worth is and feeling like
you're not getting recognized
that's frustrating yeah it's frustrating
yeah and it's like we say it's it's it's
walking that line each day and like
making those bad days good you know what
i mean like
going back to that circling back to that
that twitter beef and stuff that that
was me on a really bad day like probably
probably in the back of my head being a
bit
pissed off that i wasn't maybe where i
think i should be but you know what i
mean
there might be a bit it's going to admit
that maybe it may be maybe that
they triggered me because you know maybe
i do think
i look at certain people who come from a
certain background and think
you know like it's a privilege just to
have a bloody webcam in you in your
house like
just to be able to make a video okay
like let alone like
actually have some talent as well and
all that kind of stuff and when
you know when you've got that start and
you're not something and you're not
really showing me something that i'm all
that like impressed by
like i think maybe maybe that trip maybe
that triggers me a little bit it
triggered me a lot when i started
youtube
because in my head i'm looking at i'm
looking at how i can talk and what what
i've got to say and the life
experience i've been through yeah and
i'm seeing people who are sitting on
millions of subscribers
yeah because they open fifa parks yeah
it was a bit of a
yeah the [__] is going on yeah but it
it's uh
adapt or you know accept the environment
absolutely
yeah or you're [__] on yourself i had
to get over that and be a bit like don't
be a jealous [__]
yeah like show people how good you are
but even now
i do think i've had to [__] fly like
an eagle
to get where other people have had to
step
to yeah you know what i mean and that is
the working class thing a little bit
yeah we met you've i mean i think you're
on unreal are you
you're smashing it and like you deserve
all of this stuff and you're right you
should be
quite rightly you should be commentating
on these big fights
especially these these crossover fights
i think for a second there you weren't
being considered for it were you
oh the sky would never consider me me
i've i've said the f word a few aims
that's absolutely but also i just don't
you know like it's it's my appearance
it's where i come from yeah
it's the fact that i'm working class
like that's that's the whole thing yeah
i mean i know that plays into it
because i know there are certain
companies who wouldn't work with me for
that reason
but this is about you not about me well
it's a chat
you know i'm interested in you and your
life as well yeah it's good it's good
getting in all these things
really um no i appreciate that and one
of the things i definitely
identified with you with was when it did
all go wrong because it's gone all wrong
for me before
yeah and how you didn't give up me
and i think that that really took some
[__] balls because
yeah you know i think almost people
we love a success story but we [__]
love our
redemption story yeah you know and that
was although you kind of
on the one hand in some people's eyes
caused it yourself you're a [__]
child yeah given the world and upon your
hand of course you were going to splunk
it up the wall in a way
yeah so can you kind of describe to me
um
how the the the self-destruct button was
pressed initially
some of the things that went into the
record label going
now we're done with this guy well that
blew my mind at the time
there's just a lot of things made to be
honest like i just made a lot of poor
decisions and i think
again like i think a part of me wanted
to
i think a part of me was trying to do it
and because like while
you know like i've been a big hip-hop
fan and i made like rap music and stuff
before i went on the x-factor i made
like this hybrid music i mean i wrapped
in my audition
made like this hybrid of sort of like
blues rock
rap sort of stuff and like charlie
charlie sloth had me on um fire in the
booth
which is you know very credible it's
respected respected shaw for
mcs and it was like of course it was
backlash like letting an x factor winner
like people's people's people are so
narrow-minded they thought
hang on he can't rap because he'd come
from the x-factor that's genuinely what
some people think
so there's a bit of backlash there and
then some you know a lad
an emcee that was part of like the kind
of underground battle rap scene
um did a diss track to me and
i thought well no other x factor winner
would [__] respond to this
i'm gonna because i'm [__] real and
i'm and i was stoned off my [__] tits
drinking whatever and i went just put
the mic on and i just spat like a
freestyle on on the mic and and just put
it out not a second thought i just went
there he goes responded to him and said
some irresponsible things in there that
ultimately the media sensationalized and
took out of context
because i come from the simon cowell
machine and really i wasn't the target i
guess he
was the target well you're bound to the
the rules on you i guess i'm like
you're like a politician when you win
like when you win something like that or
you come from a tv it's like i
you know i've got you got to be some
you're held to a different standard i
suppose
in some ways you know i'm not saying
that like anyone should go around using
um you know the sort of language i was
using in that
in that thing which i didn't even think
twice about or
it was not well you're stepping into a
different game
where in rap music as i'm a big time uh
rap music fan from years
from from being 11 years old yeah you
know some of the [__] that eminem used
to say
yeah yeah we're all hailing eminem yeah
yeah no one ever brings up
some of the [__] that i mean and i'm not
asking for the guy to get cancelled i'm
a huge fan
yeah but i'm just saying that's all been
conveniently
sort of yeah whatever and we all sort of
yeah we all love eminem now but
real talk he said some of the worst [__]
you can ever yeah
i mean he he he described murdering his
own
baby bomber yeah yeah you know on you
know yeah not a problem
and the reason why we sort of
we don't condone it but we know it's
it's like any it's like a lot of artists
sometimes there's a persona that they're
playing you know there's it's like
acting isn't it
yeah just because eminem you know did
what he did in the music
yeah it doesn't mean that's his real
persona exactly yeah
he's performing exactly my whole scheme
in this like
rap dish that i did back to him was was
like like you love me don't you mate
like you
absolutely you love you wanna you you
wanna shag me and all this kind of stuff
like
because why you talking about me so much
kind of thing that was the part i was
playing
and then certain that you know there was
there was a word was used within that
that
i think we could all guess yeah that was
considered homophobic obviously and i
mean
anyone that knows me knows that that's
not even it's not even on my radar i
don't i don't think i don't
have any sort of discrimination against
anyone um
so um yeah that was kind of made
you know a big thing of and and quite
rightly because like
uh you know i shouldn't have been using
that type of language but yeah there was
just a lot of things around that time
um that i did that were just ill-advised
and was that the one direction time as
well
i think what did i say about one
direction i said something like if you
want to know
i did maurice you did your research i
think it was something along the lines
someone was saying like you're [__]
[__] compared to one direction i went
one direction sell t-shirts and
merchandise they're not mute they're not
i'm i'm a musician sort of thing
so all right so that's why they then
came back and
and louis thompson said something about
you yeah
and then you said is this my same temper
again where i was like
i don't know who you're coming that sort
of thing so so this is
again this is a fan starting it
and you've been tricked by the bait a
little bit yeah yeah
i mean all of this you know i feel like
i was one of the first people to get
cancelled like this cancel culture i
think i was like 2013 or something i
feel like i was in that
yeah yeah you were one of the first big
online guys
who was a celebrity to go through this
weird thing where yeah it was like the
you know in celebrity name here is over
party
and and so much worse has happened since
then that people
haven't been canceled over or whatever
and i and i don't agree with it i'm not
saying i'm caught again i'm not calling
for people to get cancelled and stuff
but
well you mentioned obviously caroline
flack earlier we've seen what it can do
to people like not everyone's built
to withstand yes everyone in the world
telling them their [__]
funny old things right yes you know what
i mean it's just a tragedy in it
um absolute tragedy so so it all it all
the [__] storm happened
and who how do you find out that you're
dropped from the record label who
contacted you how did that go
down oh my god you know what it was a
weird day that actually i do remember
that i remember my heart sinking
it was a weird it was a bit of sweet
thing actually i was i was at a radio
station in
brazil or some [__] like i was i can't
remember where i was but
i remember my manager coming in and
being like
so the label aren't going to take up the
next option with you
like they're not going to do the next
album
i was like what do you mean my numbers
are unbelief like i've just had a number
one album or whatever i'm like
like yeah we just can't they don't want
to be associated with you because of
your behavior and stuff like that
and put out my hearts on because i was
like ah
any x factor winner that has been
dropped or
or like yeah being dropped basically
the the odds are massively stacked
against you to ever do anything ever
again
i mean even being the next fact the win
are the odds of stuff i mean yeah
exactly that they're all
none of them really not a lot of them go
on to be massive successes yeah so then
to be dropped
yeah precisely and i was like part of me
was like
ah [__] this really is over now this
really is over and then the other part
of me is like
well you wanted this like you know i
mean you you did everything you could to
make sure that you pushed all this i
pushed everyone away i pushed all my
family away
my friends i just was just so acting so
crazy
um but yeah that was it that began a
journey of that began
two two and a half years of just severe
depression now
really so so in that moment um this is a
real low point for you
yeah the lowest yeah yeah probably who
was there for you
um who was there for me my girlfriend
was there for me
um she's massively supportive helped me
through a lot of panic attacks a lot of
a lot of um yeah a lot of just a lot of
dark times
i mean me i i was i was genuinely like
i had i had a couple of paramedics on my
whatsapp
thing like because i was ringing the
ambulances that regularly
like convinced i was having a heart
attack i mean anyone knows what it's
like to live with
um anxiety attacks feels like you're
dying and feels like you're having a
heart attack were you on medication for
this yeah i was i was
on medication at that time i'm no longer
on medication i'm completely
i don't i don't do anything now what was
it like going on the medication for you
out of interest
uh just flat i just there's a lot of
misinformation and people don't really
talk about
yes i think it's healthy to say what it
felt like i think for some people that
medication works doesn't it
and it did work for me for a short
period of time but i
i want to tread carefully with this
because
i'm not saying you can't be creative
when you're on medication but
sometimes the motivation wasn't there
for me um
well i mean it's different they often
struggle
to find the right meds for the right
person so it's a bit of a process it's a
process it's finding that balance
and and me having a sort of addictive
personality and that sort of
destruct that inner saboteur if you like
um
i was always just like you know always
playing with the idea
should i take two today so i take one or
two i was kind of [__] around
so you you all right you were kind of
making it hard for yourself i was making
it really hard for myself and
that i was just like the the demons were
just growing and growing
it's the best way i could put it um
and yeah but but ultimately um
again it goes back to that thing i was
saying about like
being happy to have those demons and
um enjoying the fact that i have that
thing in me um
because that means uh pro because it
means progress for me
without that and if i have things that
dampen it down i've just got a
[__] run a few days a week
get those the endorphins that way i'll
play some play football or bot or hit
the pads you know i mean that's that's
the thing for me personally or um be
creative
and medication is not is not for me
personally but
for a lot of people it will work and it
might work for a short period of time
but i do think that
you know um yeah
you just medication and therapy
would be my if you're going to do
medication do therapy as well
going back to the demons um as someone
who
i feel like i've got some of that [__]
in me as well yeah um
it's a it's a weird thing because um
you you say you feel like you kind of
enjoy that as well
even though it's torture at times what
do you mean by that
well like because i i'll have a day
where i'm just [__] i'm riddled with
this
thing this this um the darkness
yeah and um but i'll create something
absolutely
like something beautiful can come from
that and i can look and then the next
day i'm feeling cool i'm feeling all
right i'm not feeling some so that way
and i can look back the previous day and
i wrote
say you won't let go which has got
four billion streams or something like
that it's one of only a few songs ever
that and that must mean that i've got
something in me
there's a kid where there's capable of
something like that and if without those
demons you wouldn't have that in you
maybe
i i subscribe to the idea right now yeah
i do i think
i think i'm i'm much uh more productive
and more prolific when
um i feel like i've got something to
prove i'm
i'm motivated by competition as well
like
me getting in shape right now i put on
so much weight again during the lockdown
because i was just like sitting around
feeling like [__] again just you know
whatever
um going through one of those little
episodes and and then
i started competing with a mate like who
could burn the most calories every day
and like i've got a win and doesn't
matter if i have to take my ass outside
at 12 o'clock at night
to get those last 500 calories i'm gonna
do it because i need to win
um so i don't know i can't remember
where what my point was there but like
the motivation for me is to is to like
prove i'm good enough i suppose is to
prove that
and uh and i'll break myself in order to
do that going back to that song
um say you won't let go like very few
artists will ever know what it's like to
have
to have a hit like that and um you know
i was doing my research and i was like
[__] hell
you know because i knew it was every way
and you just it was an unescapable song
for
for a minute like for a long minute yeah
but
like for example for those who are
annoying yeah but for those who don't i
mean i
you know i like your voice it's fine but
for those who don't know
it's like 13th on spotify's all-time
most listened to you're like we're
talking drake billy eilish like
ed sheeran like you're right up there
with them yeah and there's a
you know an english artist coming from
here that's [__] crazy man because
we're used to let's be honest outside of
vegetarian and a handful of others
you know we don't it doesn't happen does
it so you really crossed into
the world with that yeah it's
it is mad to think about it i'm i'm
proud of that because
yeah it's like like you say 13th on the
um more was it like
almost listen to whoever on sports is
too ever yeah and and
the other songs are by a handful of
artists so maybe like the other songs on
that list
are produced by maybe five artists like
yeah like you said drake post malone
yeah like the big hitters and like
somehow i've made my way onto that list
so it's yeah i'm very proud of that um
can you tell me about the day you wrote
that song can you remember
writing it hung over as [__] like i was
i was in l.a right and
um i'd been one of my boys from home was
was out with me
and um we just went to this irish bar
just drank all day
and um i knew i had this session the
next day
i woke up didn't want to go it's funny
how these things like great things come
out of these sorts of things but you
know when you're hungover you're riddled
with anxiety and you don't want to go to
work you don't want to do
you don't want to go and do what you've
got shed you order now
my a and r at the time she's just like
just go along do me a favor
i'd never liked being given a brief of
like a brief
like you know can you give us a mix of
justin bieber love yourself and
lucas graham seven years like give us a
mix of them two songs in terms of the
songwriting and the feel and everything
and i was like i'm gonna go and do this
session i'm gonna do what she's asked me
to do
i'm gonna write this simple love song a
conversational love song
and i'm gonna bounce and the other two
guys in the room they must have they
must have sensed that i wanted to get
out of there quick so i wasn't feeling
good and i penned this thing
you know they you know they did help but
look they helped a little bit the
production and stuff but
i take credit for like me just doing
like taking the reins in that session
and just going
here you go put the vocal down i didn't
think anything of it and for a long time
when everyone was going mad about this
song going this is the [__] best song
we've ever heard like
internally the label and everyone are
like this is this song's [__] unreal
and i'm like
i think it's corny as [__] i hate this
song
they were like this is your comeback
singer i was like no chance no i need to
come back with
a big redemption song about how i've
overcome my demons and all this [__]
they were like nah this is the song and
and and i kind of went with it
and just shows what i know about like
you know a and r and stuff like that
because it was
i remember just on this one day um
it went to number one in the charts i
got a call from psycho asking me to come
back to them
they wanted to resign me they wanted me
to come back on x factor and perform all
the things that's
like seemed like a pipe dream oh you
love me now do you yeah it
it was always that yeah and then um all
of that [__] happened on the same day
and i was just like
what the [__] it was like a dream um
so yeah i mean that song is just it it
just turned my life i was in debt
at that point as well i was like two
hundred three hundred grand in debt
i was from was it just lifestyle just
lifestyle i didn't even realize that i'd
got myself in that debt
it was like my account was like you're
kind of in the red here i was going to
more or less
yeah i don't know like a bit of gambling
but you know what i like to bet on
football and [__]
um and uh i mean you must have put some
big bets on pulse
but clearly you weren't living
responsibly then you were just wild as
[__] at that point
wild and and they were sending me to
like [__] moldova or romania every
friday night to sing impossible and make
like 10 g's or something
like that was my life at that point and
everything was resting on whether or not
i could write this album
or write a song that could get me back
on the radio basically and say one to go
did it
it's funny because um yeah i've
i don't know it's a bit of a battle with
that because like you say you wanted
that redemption song but then yeah come
on with the love song and like you say
you're like oh that's corny
because in that moment when you're
thinking about that person obviously
like women especially connected with it
because obviously
it's about making them feel a certain
way yeah and actually the way you talked
about writing it
really reminded me of uh when robbie
williams wrote angels it was quite a
similar sort of
hungover yeah it's funny how uh you guys
work i don't know what it is i think
maybe we're just a little bit looser
or something like that what do you in
terms of you know you talk about
impossible and how you're
a bit you're [__] sick of singing it
um this song
well like like angels for robbie you
know
you're gonna be [__] 50 yeah and
people are going to want to hear this
and they're not going to want to hear
your version paul no they want this
they want the radio don't [__] yeah
no they're not going to be letting you
know
i don't [__] with that to be honest no
you can't i don't really have to sing it
at this point luckily
you know it's easy it's kind of it's
kind of cool that's amazing it's always
an amazing moment when we play that song
because
you leave that the last that's last year
every time yeah
it's yeah and they just sit they do just
sing it from start to finish
and i just feared that's it's amazing
what was the um
what was the friends and family reaction
like to that moment of redemption
and when you've got it back
i think they were probably as shocked as
i was because do you know what halfway
through my like sort of meltdown
breakdown whatever you want to call it
not be not having a deal for two years
and going through all this
um depression and whatever like
there was a point where i remember
saying to people around me i was like
i'm gonna fight here i'm gonna see if i
can do this i'm gonna see if i can come
back
i'm gonna write that song i'm gonna do
i'm gonna get
back on x factor and be make this mad
comeback
and everyone you know i knew everyone
thought i was deluded oh yeah they're
probably
you know you know when like the the old
footballers and the pub going i could
have i could have done it
yeah i mean you sound a bit like that
then don't oh and i knew it
but i just kept doing it because i like
subscribed to that whole
putting things out there into the
universe sort of vibe you know i
i subscribe to all that um manifestation
and stuff and
and i thought if i kept saying it no
matter how deluded i sounded because
that's how i got where i got in the
first place i told everyone i was going
to be this [__]
this this superstar or whatever when i
was younger
i'm going to be a singer and i never i
never wavered from that um
and i kind of went back to that i
suppose in them two years and told
everyone i was going to make this
comeback and
no matter how unrealistic that seemed
i was just going to keep on putting it
out there and i wonder how much that
played a part in
in the whole thing do you think after
having everything
and losing everything yeah and then
getting everything back
you now appreciate it properly
yeah i mean it took when the comeback
happened it did take me a couple of
years to process that again as well it
was like winning all over again
um it was like getting that moment all
over again so and and i felt like it was
going to get
stripped away from me again i felt like
that was the paranoia
paranoia was there the whole time i was
like oh [__] have i like you know
done something wrong is there anything
because someone going to come out you
know that whole thing or
have i so but yeah i just i lived with
that for two years man
i lived with it for two years and and
then it just was like
no i'm cool i'm cool and i think that's
probably why i didn't really follow up
the success of say he won't let the gore
that go on a big way it was very
difficult to um
very difficult to emulate the success of
that as as we've talked about it being
just anomaly of a song um what it's done
like views wise and streams and stuff
we're talking like billions of views
billions of streams so i guess i was
trying to like
maybe maybe do it again maybe that's
what them two years i was like
gotta do that again good and it just
became a bit draining and i've now got
to a point where i'm just like making
music i want to make and
that's that's the way i'm moving forward
speaking of which actually the creative
process
yeah you mentioned that the label we're
going right if we could just have a bit
of justin bieber in there but sprinkle a
little bit of this other hit song in
there
that'll be [__] champion and you you
actually did it yeah
you know i think we've spoken before on
the phone um
about creative integrity versus
hits yeah and you definitely seem to
struggle a little bit with that in the
past of battling what the record label
want
from you versus who you feel you really
are yeah how are you finding
that moving forward i'm uh
i really feel like i'm in a place now
where i'm on my
i'm on my fourth studio album like with
a major label
uh i feel like i've earned my stripes i
spent the last year
spent 2020 um doing a lot of soul
searching and
i made i made this new album at my house
which was like just
a revelation because i i've always hated
you know major levels will like they
will send you out on this like tour of
um yeah studio super producers like oh
this guy just wrote a hit with selena
gomez you're gonna go write a song with
him and like i've always hated it just i
just think like
you spend one day reading the room and
getting past the sort of
social anxieties and then the next day
you might create something good whereas
like the whole process this time
i was able to be vulnerable i was in my
own spit my own like um
sanctuary um and it just meant
that i made the best most personal album
i could have made i think that doesn't
seem like the best way well i mean i'm
i'm the expert but like part of the
reason the artist that i like seem to
like going back to eminem we mentioned
earlier he worked with dr dre they knew
each other inside out yeah that's why
the chemistry was amazing so to go meet
a guy and then we expect to knock a hit
out within a day of meeting someone he
seems
[__] mental to me yeah and i agree it
works for some people it's never
worked for me not to say that i haven't
gotten some amazing things out of doing
that
but i've just it's just i don't think
the creative process should be stressful
and maybe i'm not the type of
personality to be doing that and
and like um i don't like the feeling of
of feeling like you've got to earn your
stripes in a room like
i i feel like i've done i've been
through that
and being on my fourth album and you
know producing
albums that have been successful um on
on a couple of occasions i
um i just i i want creative
like full creative control now and i've
got that so in answer your question i'm
really happy with where i am
as like an artist and as a business and
yeah from top to bottom i'm kind of
across everything which wasn't always
the case you know it was
it was a process i've had to release
things that maybe i didn't really
believe in
you know just to just to plug a gap to
keep me going keep me relevant
uh you know on the advice of a label or
or pr whatever it may be you know
i think you've been edging closer though
because i noticed on the third album
the first two were quite similar
although
yeah uh the second one
uh i felt the progress yeah clearly but
it was in a similar style
exactly the third one there was a bit
more flavor in there like that treehouse
song for example
yeah that was like oh he's he's going in
a bit of a different direction yeah like
this
yeah yeah what is your creative process
then
now yeah i'm glad you said that because
that's really
been the mission is like getting here
where i am now and i think if you like
stuff like that you're gonna love this
album
creative process for me i think i'm like
i think i'm a melody
guy really like i think if i if a melody
resonates with me then
everything else is very easy to me like
the the
conversational lyrics and stuff is sort
of
where my skill lies i think um so once
you've got the melody down everything
else sort of falls off yeah yes yeah i
think melody's
just really important that that would be
my it's a part it's a boring answer to a
really good question
and you know i know a lot of people have
like so interesting processes but for me
like
if i make if i'll make a beat or like
put some cards down or whatever i'll
play some cards in the guitar
um i'll just spit ball melodies for ages
i just spit i'll just sing and sing
melodies and and
and so one fits so one fits and one
feels like is that a verse or and then
it's the question of is that a verse is
that a pre-chorus is that
is that the say you won't let go on
mormon is you know what i mean is that
um is that something that people are
going to walk around singing and then
you hum it or something do you like
without actually putting words in did
you start homemaking i have this i have
this way of like singing
where it sounds like i'm saying stuff
but i'm not really singing
i'm not really saying the words i'm just
kind of so you put the words in later so
yeah it's kind of slot them in later
i mean sometimes like you get a phrase
and are a concept
sometimes but on the whole my thing is
like melody really
actually there's that i was listening to
the album before you came
and i wanted to talk to you about some
lyrics because there was one
there was an opening of a song and i
remember the first time i heard it and i
was like
you're talking to me james i feel you
yeah yeah um
okay i'm going to read them out to you
guys this might get awkward oh yes sorry
it's cool
every lad will will connect with this in
my opinion yeah
how can someone so beautiful as you be
such a terrible human
i'm gonna keep going yeah i lay in bed
at night and wonder myself
what the [__] are we doing yeah but i
like the way you always stand up
for yourself but you gotta take it too
far and you drag me through hell
honey you know how to turn me around
don't know what
i don't know how you do it so let's
smoke let's drink until we're [__] in
the bathroom leaning over the sink
i'm listening to this just like i mean
women can connect with that and think
it's about a man but yeah
for for that really spoke to me because
like you could be in a relationship and
just be like
what are we [__] doing but then next
thing you know you're over the sink
yeah he said like how does stuff like
that just come into your head
is that from personal experience or is
that yeah
do you know what as i uh you've got a
sink i'm sure you know
yeah i've got a sink you've used it now
and again
um i just think like it's very easy like
in theory to say
just write some [__] that like people
can relate to that like is it
would be a conversation and people a lot
of people do that
well but when it's done really well
where like you've sung a melody but the
lyrics are saying something like that
saying something that you would say to
you or think about you misses
like and you can make it feel like it's
a conversation but it's also hooky
there's a there's a lot of it's like
multifaceted isn't it
that's so boring and like songwriter no
but yeah but you're you
i get you're a trained lyricist at this
point so you can break things down on a
technical level
yeah i guess you're at that moment
i'm assuming you're just laying back and
thinking about how you felt at certain
times and wondering
how can i put this into a story and make
it sound good
it actually came from like um i was
talking to this
this guy egg white who's just like this
legend
in the game we got in a room together
and we started writing the song we were
talking about relationships and like
wanted to make this kind of sexy song
and he started doing these [__] cool
ass
like roads things and and um
i was like what's it like for you like
been married for a hundred years or
whatever
how long however long you've been when
you're missing just like i [__] hate
or sometimes
and i was like i'm gonna use that like
but but you know ultimately he'd stayed
with her that long because he
because he loved her and like he knows
at the end of the day they'll have a
little drink
maybe whatever they do and then they'll
probably go on tap and everything will
be fine
i mean yeah and like something as simple
as that and something so real is very
pure and um honest isn't it so
yeah i mean he he inspired that to be
fair i've noticed your live shows
you go for it you i mean it wasn't just
for x factor like you really give the
audience everything you have
yeah what is it like being on tour
generally oh man i love i love being on
tour
i mean it's tiring it's exhausting and i
put a lot of pressure on myself when i'm
on tour because i have to
there's a level of vocals that i want to
produce every night and
i know that you can't burn the candle
but i learned that
in my first couple of tours like you
can't be smoking weed till [__] six
o'clock in the morning on the tour bus
and then get up and
smash out impossible or whatever i've
got to do the next night it's just not
because your voice is special and you
know how do you look after it
it's it's been a lot trial and error
with me it's been a lot it's been that's
been a real challenge for me because i
because i
i don't really like to be in my head
when i'm performing thinking
save yourself for tomorrow you got to do
this again tomorrow night like i do
want to i do want to give you the whole
shebang everything i want everyone to
feel this
have the same moment every night that's
that's my thing that's my problem i
suppose it's not a problem
it's a blessing and a curse really but
um
yeah i've struggled with it i've tried
i've kind of finally nailed it now i
just have to do like
two shows and have two days off and then
two shows and i'm at a point now where i
can tailor the tours
to suit the sort of how demanding the
vocals are in a lot of a lot of our
songs so
going back to music artists that you
listen to growing up
yeah uh who were your the ones who
really made you fall in love with music
um
so my my mom played a lot of uh
played a lot of the greats really just a
lot like you know stevie wonder and
michael jack michael jackson mainly i
think was the one for was my guy
when i was a kid that's what i wanted
you know i wanted to sing like him and
stuff
uh but then i'd go over to my dad's
house and my dad would be playing black
sabbath and
thin lizzy and led zeppelin and the who
the who was my dad's that
really makes sense listening to your
albums because it
it does feel like it's yeah it's a class
yeah it's it is and um
and you know that's why i had this new
album i wanted to make it more coherent
you'll hear it's more of a cohesive body
of work but yeah i think
sometimes i've put too many styles
together but that's probably because of
the influences i was hearing when i was
younger it was rock and it was
it does feel like a weird fusion
sometimes when i'm listening i'm like
pick who you want to be james totally
yeah i agree with you on certain tracks
i'm
like yeah um and in the you know you're
nobody still somebody loves you i i
found that a bit
ah um i like this but it's also a weird
mix of
so much gone in there yeah um whereas
obviously
say you won't let go is very much just
it's just one this is who i am
yeah i found i found it hard to really
pick a lane i think because i want to do
so many things i've
i like the idea of being versatile and
being good at lots of different genres
and are you going to rap more
this new album is yeah there's a fair
bit of wrap on it good
it's kind of more trappy sort of thing
yeah the trappy rock sort of porcelain
alone
i think you've got it in you you do that
style for sure yeah
when you describe melodies yeah if
there's someone who's the king of
melodies it's post malone in my opinion
like
he i don't think he's the greatest
lyricist in the world but melodies
this guy nails melodies yeah yeah him
and this the
producer he works with their i think he
caught
andrew what i think he's called yeah
they're just a [__] force to be
reckoned with
yeah they smash it what about um you did
a song with mjk
yeah uh are you do he he seemed to like
you spoke very highly of you
yeah he's my boy yeah we um
i've done a couple of shows with him
here and there and uh
we're actually we're she working on some
bits and bobs as well yeah
because because i did i was on a couple
of albums ago
um and i'm working on something with
travis barker right now
who i've collaborated with on he was on
the last album
yeah and um yeah i think we're gonna mgk
might be involved in some ways
which is really exciting so talented
this guy mgk is yeah
yeah yeah he's he's seen him in the
movie yeah yeah he's like
he's very dirt yeah he's class running
he was actually really [__] good he
was classy i was shocked that how
like talented he is an actor and he can
do it all this yeah he's he's like he's
the yardstick like it's kind of where
where i want to
get to as well is doing all that all of
that stuff is
to be taken seriously for the rap stuff
for the rock stuff for the pop stuff
and then the acting stuff as well like
that's really you know he's really
nailing that to be fair
what do you think when him and eminem
are going back and forth because i think
the whole
the whole world because you're an eminem
massive eminem
but the whole world was like mgk's this
was actually [__] sick it was like it
was
actually really good it was it was a
hard one because it's weird in it
because you're like being
you know eminem's like the gods and if
you're in a rap
mgk had done better than anyone eminem
has ever come up against he's buried
them hasn't he
yeah there's been no one who's really
tested him and mgk did like everyone
loved the tune
i don't necessarily think that his bars
were as good as eminem's were when he
came back
the other one you know technically when
you break it down but it had hooks in it
the bait was good as well
it was classy he made a sick video and
he said some pretty cutting things in he
saw
yeah i mean i mean a lot of people think
he won that battle i think it's a bit
like um
going against the heavyweight champion
and doing better than anyone had done
before so you kind of win
so and also better than anyone thought
he would do yeah so he kind of won
anyway
100 yeah he's i mean he couldn't have
done better in that situation could he
really
smashed it i want to come on the kickoff
one time as well you [__] know it
we'll definitely it
i'd love that come together talk about
the border yeah we'd love that um
but we're talking about women now women
great good good mrs is over there that's
cool great subject can't wait
sorry about it no but um i was i was
thinking about
you know when i started talking about
earlier about you flirting with women
and all of this on the x factor for a
bit of a
laugh obviously yeah but how it was
like before x factor yeah versus during
an after x factor
and how you adapted to a change where
all of a sudden
you're not the chaser you're the one
being chased because that's a bit of a
head [__] for many men
very difficult and i don't think people
really appreciate because it's such a
great problem to have
yeah how difficult it can be to manage
that problem and how how did you find
that
um it's a good question um
well i think that it definitely became a
problem 100 became a problem
yeah it's a weird one knowing it because
everyone's like
[__] prick but like yeah but it's
it's like being
i guess an addict to
to food and all of a sudden food becomes
free like and
you're just in this [__] you know
you're doing all the wrong things
probably i mean it's not i
don't know how to put this in like uh
like i say i'm not media trained or
anything so it's a good thing
so it's probably a good thing but like i
mean you grow up coming from the back
ass of nowhere like i
really insignificant town [__] for
one of a better phrase [__]
wanking over these nuts magazines and
these women that you never think you're
gonna [__] ever
ever have and like you know these
yeah you know you've got a graph to get
to get girls and stuff like i mean
i did all right cause i was in a rock
band and stuff like that um
but then you know i mean for any guy
like who hasn't got
how do i put this all of a sudden um
there was no graft involved at all with
getting with getting
girls and like i just thought this was
it this was normal this is the culture
you get you just don't have to work hard
like
she wants it i want it there's no like
and like so you go and do a show
you get a girl and and then before you
know it you're just like
dming girls like left them right and sex
becomes like
the focus but you're james arthur as
well so what happens when
you're all right now i'm off to the the
next town
and i'll see you later how does that get
dealt with like
you know was it just like yeah okay fine
or you know
did you get into situations where it was
like a whole big [__] mess and people
wouldn't accept things
yeah that's a good point yeah i
definitely i definitely
you wouldn't think i'm not exactly
[__] brad pitt or out but i broke a
few hearts along the way and i
definitely like threat some girls in a
way that i regret
just because i thought you know because
i was getting away with it i suppose and
like
and i was speaking to women at one point
in a way that
like you know i'm not proud of in the
sense that like
i just kind of like you do when you're
in the public eye and i suppose if
when it becomes easy and you're getting
girls and things like that you sort of
like take it for granted i heard i heard
a lad talking about
someone someone in the public eye a
famous singer talking about how
like he ended up sleeping with a fan and
like
afterwards it became very clear to him
that like she'd only slept with him
because his music
had gotten her through a really bad time
and he never thought once about that he
just thought
she wants to have sex i want to have sex
and was going to do it
men don't question [__] like that do we
we're just like
what sex okay then yeah but as you get
older you know i've got four sisters and
like um and and i love them daily and
like the thought of any man like
treating them as an object or or well
maybe you were the object as well
exactly well yeah i mean there is that
there's a lot of things that play there
um
did you ever feel like that because in
my in periods of my life i realized
in maybe not treating women with as much
respect as i should have done i was also
disrespecting myself at the time as well
because i'm like
hold on a second i'm starting to feel
worthless because
yeah i just do this without thinking
yeah so therefore
it's not good for me either really yeah
like although it feels great at the time
and all of that
yeah it's a bizarre situation as a man
to find a certain way i'm like
my self-esteem is going down here yeah
and ultimately it's for
like it's a lot of it's for validation
isn't it you know
it's the thing about kind of what we
went back to earlier kind of
being told you know you're not this
you're not that
so when you're in you know i guess a
situation with a beautiful woman you're
like
look at me i'm i'm the [__] man i can
do this every night with a different
woman like you get this
horrible complex yeah yeah um did you
feel that
yeah no definitely at times i come you
know
yeah of course you know you're punching
well above your weight a lot of the time
and you're thinking
how real is this you know you question
and and
um them just wanting to sleep with you
um no longer like at a certain point
stops validating you
it stops being enough really it's sort
of
um you realize like you have to really
like you
like you know um that's the that's the
case it's true wouldn't it yeah
yeah and and i you know i mean i
for me was like it's a lot of
titillation a lot of time i wouldn't
even meet up with girls and like have
sex with just knowing that they were
into me or they wanted to chat to me and
i could have had them like was
was a problem for me at one point and it
was affecting my relationships and stuff
and um
and you know that's something i think
anyone in my position would struggle
with
um and it's obviously got it it's gotten
me in trouble and made me look a certain
way in the past
that i definitely regret you know those
moments are
my regrets you know where like people
might have thought that i was a
womanizer or whatever because that's
really when you get to know me i'm not
um
let's say i've got four sisters and now
i hate the you know i hate the thought
of
you know it's really it's a really
interesting one this because
although i've like off the back of my
fame and successful i got with a lot of
girls like
i never i think i was always very
respectful
really to be honest i think i've i think
i've always like wanted to have a
connection with those
with those girls but maybe i left them
behind too
quick and like just [__] [__] them off
yeah like i mean
it's hard to know what you've got in
front of you when so much is happening
and there's so many people in front of
you and yeah and
and there may be a situation where
you've got
very good girls who would treat you very
well but you're not valuing it because
it's
it's not unusual and it and things just
become
absolutely meaningless at that point and
i guess i through all of that
situation that you went through at some
point like you said
where's the meaning in this is that when
you started thinking more about having a
relationship with someone
yeah yeah definitely and um
you know me and me and my missus we've
had our ups and downs and now we're off
moments and stuff and
because because of the the things we're
talking about because of my
my focus uh in the past being on the sex
and just like getting that validation
from women and stuff obviously
stemming back to my childhood not having
the self-worth and all that kind of
stuff like it's been
it's been an issue but ultimately i
think
you know when you've got a partner um
and i believe
i believe in love i believe in you know
partnership and
i think i mean i wouldn't be here um she
she got me through some really [__]
dark times so i feel kind of indebted to
her and who knows where i've been if i
didn't have that
relationship so i'm definitely like i'm
for that whole
thing um yeah i don't really know where
i'm going with this no it's cool man i i
like
i like that you're just sort of riffing
and giving it honestly because that's
what that's what podcasts are about
exactly yeah and again just to reiterate
this is my first one anyone who's
watching so this this is me like
learning on the job in a way
you're doing great it's fun um so yeah
on that topic
um did you ever fear of someone being
with you for the wrong reasons now
because yes
you got the money you know you can look
after a woman yeah and let's be real
like um
you know babies come along very easy
when i mean just ask drake
yeah yeah yeah it can happen yeah no
absolutely i've questioned
that 100 i've questioned it in the
relationship i'm in now like
you know what you're with me for like
what the [__]
like you know could be with anyone um
yeah definitely of course uh i suppose
as you get older you start to
you start to sort of
give less of a [__] what other people
think really don't you in general
and that's kind of where i'm at i think
have you ever had your heart broken
yeah of course yeah only really i think
only once though
what was it i never allowed it to happen
again tell me what it was like i want to
know like
not you know tell me what you feel
comfortable with but yeah
what was it like it was my it was my
first girlfriend
um once that happened maybe maybe like
yeah i know i never i never allowed it
to happen again i never allowed myself
to
be as vulnerable as well i was
vulnerable because i have made myself
very vulnerable in other relationships
but how old were you
i was only 7 16 17. bro this is it right
yeah the first time you get with a girl
though
you you go so [__] you give
everything don't you like yeah yeah
forever
oh yeah because you feel it and yeah
i've never even had a proper
good i never really had a proper
girlfriend until that point either it
was always just like
you know and coming from a situation
where obviously you were talking about
your mom and dad um
yeah you know maybe struggling is
to trust people when you really gave her
that trust it probably was like
yeah put everything into it then i
learned from i learned a lot from that
from that breakup
because i learned that i was putting
all of the things that i'd lacked from
the support from my
mom and dad i was putting all that on in
this relationship i was
everything was dependent on this little
bubble i was in with this girl
and um she broke up with me out of
nowhere we just we just
to her i guess like we didn't we weren't
interested in the same things anymore
you know you're 16 17 whatever and then
she got with another lad like a week
later and i was like [__] you know i was
i was wounded i was like i thought you
were like probably i remember it
like that being like oh what's wrong
with me is it the same thing as like
this
no no i had the exact same break up you
honestly and it [__] me up for a long
time and then every other girlfriend i
was like i'm the [__] man in this
relationship
and you know just knowing i'm the prize
and like this kind you know what i mean
it was
it was um i just did she rocked your
confidence yeah she rocked it
she rocked it bad and then um yeah no i
just
i made sure that like i could trust
every girl i'd ever been with and and
i'd never got past the two years
uh two year mark with a girl until my my
um current girlfriend i'd never got past
it because after two years i'd just get
like a bit bored i'd be like
like this i don't know what it was you
say it bored
do you know this like quest of
validation that we we all have
do you think as soon as you knew like
maybe i got you now
yeah you're willing to stay with me
forever yeah you sort of feel like you
have
the completed the game now 100 that's
what it was yeah yeah 100
men's eagles man
i've met lads uh i've had people sit in
that very chair say that to me before
it's like once i know i've got you
yeah it's like um it was that i think it
was that on a on you know
and that's why women end up being like
scared to
compliment men yeah you know when girls
never compliments because like the last
guy they complimented tracked them like
[__] because he thought he had her
yeah yeah and then it's like then
they're scared to
to give as well exactly then later on
in your 20s and 30s we're meeting people
where
both sides are scared because they've
both been tracked like that before
100 and and you know what that's what
made me stick out this
this most recent one for as long as i
have and um
because you know this meant there's many
reasons but one of the main ones being
like
i can't be the guy that can't [__]
hold down a relationship because of my
ego
and you know what i mean i thought i
need i need to get that in check
and value the other person in the
relationship as long as they're adding
value to my life
obviously and we're adding value to each
other it's a tricky one though to stay
to stay uh dedicated as well because
yeah
um when you are who you are and you're
meeting as many people as you are
um back in the day when we had
like marriage was brought into play you
know people weren't
living a lifestyle that you are me no
and having options
constantly presented on a regular basis
yeah
and yeah but it's all you're only human
so you're going to look
generally everyone looks do you think
it's like that for everyone now a bit as
well though
oh mate with social media almost
it's like it's worse for you ten times a
hundred times what two million times or
whatever it is how many followers you
got
yeah but yeah the world's i think
having a long-term relationship is
becoming so difficult because the
options
yeah because of tinder and all these
other [__] things yeah yeah
people are constantly going maybe the
grass is greener
yeah and um it isn't there wasn't that
temptation that uh
you know when i was when you know in our
parents generation yeah no [__] way
it just didn't yeah it didn't
exist it was a night out they had to go
through a night out yeah make it home
yeah my dad didn't cheat or whatever
then well you've got now you've got like
whatever you have 24 7.
looking at in your search feed on
whatever algorithm starts showing you
all the things you like and then you
start going oh i got that and then
it's all the big officers for us all the
people
i mean it's like everyone's squatting
these days yeah
yeah um but yeah it's kind of [__]
mentally i don't think it's healthy but
i also don't know how we change it
because
we're heading towards a society who
cannot
maintain a relationship yeah the minute
anyone hits the rocks
yeah like i think our parents generation
because your same age me roughly they
were the first ones to
regularly get divorced divorce became
really normal generation before them
they'd be like you [__] stick out no
matter what man you got married stick it
stick out yeah
but this generation it's removed even
further it's not you don't even make it
to the divorce they're only making a
marriage because the minute anything
gets hard
yeah they go onto their [__] phone
and they're like big ass
sarcasm right yeah general i mean yeah i
don't know what
i don't know how the [__] we sort this
out like honestly hey i
i know what you say it's it's it
it's a it's a very it's a weird one it's
definitely okay it's definitely
not good yeah you're right though like
people are going to be scared to have an
argument yeah someone picks their phone
i think for me like the way maybe that
competitive thing comes in for me again
somewhere just to circle back to that
whole thing where i think
i think maybe you should be when you're
in a relationship you should be
motivated by
um one wanting to be a good partner
because you see all the values in that
other person and because of what they
bring to you
not to be soppy as [__] but uh your spot
on it yeah
and i think i think if that's not the
objective if that's not the motivation
then don't be in it that's sort of and
like if
you know what i mean because if you
aren't motivated by wanting to be class
for that other person
then it's not right and maybe you're in
it for the wrong reasons and maybe
that's why a lot of relationships are
are going when they shouldn't be yeah so
when you stop doing the little things
that
make the other person smile yeah you
know it's it's
it's almost done then isn't it because
you're just not trying
yeah once you're not trying to jump out
a little bit because i've
i've let myself quit she's looking over
all the eyes she's going he's talking
he [__] slipped up a few times and
got a bit lazy but
like you know i know when i really need
to pull it back and um
it's probably what's kept things going
we're going to interview her
we'll cross examine
what motivates you at this point joe i
just
i like the idea of like [__] just
having a
having a year where i'm in like connor
says i'm coming for all the belts you
know like just
the brit awards the grammys oh man it
sounds so wanky to say like i just
because i shouldn't really be i
shouldn't be striving for the industry's
respect like for the music indus respect
or
for glastonbury who asked me to play and
things like that um
nah but i know deep down it's just like
it's that's validation yeah
it's just i mean that does more of it if
i didn't have that then i suppose
i can be happy with what i've achieved
definitely you know
um i've got some pretty good numbers and
things like that and i'm happy with it
i'm happy that i've wrote a love song
that will be a timeless
classic i suppose and a big part of a
lot of people's wedding days and [__]
forever probably
which is like should be enough really
shouldn't it but it isn't
it's not enough no i want more i want i
want the [__] what do you want people
to think about when they
when they hear the new album what do you
want them to feel about that i really
i really like the idea of people going
he can [__] do anything and it's kind
of
he he can do it with mutant in terms of
music like
he's got it's like a mixed martial
artist i'm the most well-rounded cat
there is
you know what i mean like um and i'm
just saying there's like uh
sean mendes has got this but j but
james alvarez got that and then he's got
this and he's got that and he's got that
you know what i mean and
like on a technical thing like
it would be i'd be lying if i said i
would i wouldn't like to get to a point
where
people would putting me up there and i
know they're reluctant too
who do you want to be i want names here
no because i i know how you work now i'm
i'm feeling the vibes right right
there's people on your list that you
want to be better than i i feel like
you're
that you must be wanting to be better
like is there any anyone i don't i don't
necessarily want to be better than them
i don't want to be better lion i just
want to i'm sure
no i did i don't because because there's
guys i really respect like
you know ed sheeran was a bit of a
mentor for me coming up he was really
good to me really supportive and stuff
and
he's he's the guy he's the yardstick
he's he's nailed it
um but i think i've i've got i've got
the same tools as him
and i'm maybe they've got a couple more
and like
but i'm not doing the stadiums i don't
know maybe it's my personality maybe
it's
you know i don't know what i don't know
what it is he's a weird one for me you
know because i've never clicked with his
music i don't actually um
i i'm the outsider yeah i don't know
what it is about him
yeah i think it it's a bit soft for me
it's right
it's for the women and i respect that
yeah and i think there's men up there
who love it as well for some reason i
just
he's uh he's probably too likeable for
me i mean he's so he's so likable and so
and so good and he is like you know i
shouldn't say i've got
i've got more in my locker than him but
but maybe i do have that side that maybe
he doesn't have which is like
and i like to hear guys like you
resonate with my music because that's
ultimately i'm so grateful for the
female fan base the
predominantly predominant female from
fanbase that i've got
young and old it's a real cross-section
of women but
there's nothing more there's nothing i
love more than to see a guy like you in
the front row
like a cool ass [__] with tats
on that like liking my music because it
means like
i've resonated with people that are like
me and think like me you know i
i think i'm i'm maybe that's that's
where i'm different to some of the other
other
guys in my lane like you start you open
the podcast by saying that like
um maybe he's that guy that you can [__]
with
oh yeah when i was watching x factor i'm
like oh yeah you can break up
with me that yeah i mean i wish i could
sing like that yeah and if i could have
a voice
that would speak for the pain i
feel that's what i would want to sound
like yeah you know i love to hear that
more than
more than anything so it pays off so
much for me and that's why i think it
hurts me when i see a lot of young
lads who like who get me wrong and like
go that [__] just sings for [__]
old women
i know what you mean they get me wrong
and i don't like it i want i want them
to to feel me i suppose like when people
from newcastle slag me off
a little bit me oh yeah i heard that
because in my head i'm like
i put you on my back my name is true
jordan yeah everything about me he
carried the city
i'm literally trying i'm i'm not hunting
deck but guess what
no one in newcastle's like aunt and
[__] dick yeah lotties look like me
actually yeah yeah so supporters jeremy
i do you get that because
maybe you speak because because you do a
podcast you maybe speak a bit
more clearly sometimes or like enunciate
a bit better like
people say i've lost my borax and i'm
like well i can't get on the stroller
[__] here like me
what we'll do right now is i can't i've
absolutely had to
to shave it a little bit yeah no one
[__] understood me when i came when i
came out and i was like i'm sick of
people saying
what are you talking to me so yeah i
know i absolutely i get you
and um how do you feel about do you what
is the hometown value like with you are
they like
hold you up how do they because you are
the guy
you're the one i don't know i don't know
it's a weird one a gauge for me that
like when i'm there people
people have been nothing but lovely to
me i don't feel necessarily like
hailed as like you should be i don't
necessarily feel that
but i think i come from quite a rough
place like boris is
a tough town where people don't like you
getting above your station
we've got people from america who listen
to this
and other places yeah he's not lying
right borah is rough as [__] it's
rough absolutely it's honestly it's been
voted the worst place to live for about
10 years running i think but
that diamonds are you know made in
places like that only yeah
100 but and you know and i'm grateful
for
to come from that culture and it goes
back to again the thing we were talking
about earlier it's like
um we're very very real there if you're
gonna you're gonna say something to me
like you're gonna talk about my family
and we're fighting like it's or
if you know um
yeah i was just brought up to fight back
it's a bit it's
we've got we've got in borough we've got
the worst unemployment rate in the in
the country
we all we always have and um you know
there's a lot of depression and a lot of
like
hardship there they're forgotten just
like the people in newcastle yeah no one
gives you
around the northeast like it's a it's a
hard working place and
yeah i don't know we just i did i feel
like it's it's different there
people if you if you're not real and
you're not
true to yourself uh they sort it out
straight away
like i i can't walk around that town
thinking i'm [__] billy big bollocks
because someone will bring me down
you know what i mean so um yeah i don't
know i don't really feel like i'm gonna
get a statue
or anything uh made in my honor that's
weird though because when you think that
like
you're like we said at the start x
factor winner is one thing but to be on
the spotify
yeah the the spotify list for most
listened to songs since it began
you know they should be i feel the love
don't get me wrong i feel the love i've
definitely got a lot of fans from from
that area that pack out
you know um the venues down there and
stuff i just
yeah i don't know britain in general um
i think uh i wonder whether people have
had an opportunity to really get to know
me to be fair
i don't think they have really i hope
this is the start of that i do too
understanding you better and realizing
you know you're not perfect but you're
not trying to be perfect and i think
that's what you're
about whereas when we look at the
one directions and the other massive
successes from the uk
yeah i think there is a a bit of that
isn't it you know i mean like not
they're not i'm not trying to set you up
to dig the lights or whatever i'm just
saying
to come out from the jump and go yeah
yeah you know yeah by the way on the one
direction stuff not that i need
like address it that much but i i've um
since that whole thing and by the way
they are really you know a lot of them
lads are really talented and what i said
was
what was stupid at the time but i've you
know become mates with some of them and
they're
they're you know salt of the earth good
good people and
um yeah that was it really it's all
launched just squashed it yeah yeah
there's no there's nothing there anymore
at all what are you insecure about what
am i insecure about
if there's what was the main thing that
you think is your
oh i'll show about this i cut my
my right eye on a glass table when i was
when i was a nipper
and you're probably not so don't keep an
awful lot of eye contact
um because um
yeah it sort of severed the nerves in
one of my eyes when when i was a kid and
um
it's always been a thing like if if i'm
keeping a lot of eye contact with you
know i trust you because it's something
i'm always always i've always been wary
of it's a weird thing to
talk about i've never talked about that
in public but um
yeah it's a it's a weird thing i've
always had like does it make you nervous
of it
no no we're having a lot when i'm tired
like it's
it's because it's like a lazy eye if you
like when i'm tired and i've had a long
day like
it's something that's that that's in the
back of my head it's funny because i
notice your eyes were
changing a little bit as the podcast
went on you know oh really i'm not just
making this up i thought i hope he's not
getting tired but now he said that it
makes total sense
yeah oh hopefully it's not picking up
the camera but
whatever i do get conscious of that like
that i suppose if
like a like a physical insecurity but
that's a normal thing you know uh people
with autism for example
um struggle with eye contact sometimes
yeah um it can
be brought on by all sorts of things i
thought i had that at one point because
of that very reason but now
you never know i mean we're all on the
spectrum yeah
but um what was i gonna say uh what are
you most confident about
um about yourself my i'd say my
my um my musical of my musical ability
yeah my ability to write songs and sing
live
perform yeah when did you know you had
that voice because
i remember that i always knew you were
[__] class but i remember the one
one of the songs i watched you perform
on youtube where i was like
wow yeah uh wrecking ball wrecking ball
yeah me
i watched that i'm not a massive miley
cyrus fan although she's
[__] great yeah she's she's she's
cool as [__] you know
but you destroyed the original version
you brought
you absolutely like i was like they
should never have given this
this is you you that's your song now by
the way like do you reckon
you've you've you've actually like yeah
it's your song
oh man that was that was a real that was
a class moment to be fair i didn't i did
i mean i didn't expect to have like a
viral moment out of that at all like
it's one of them where
i'm touring around german radio stations
and they're like can you give us one of
your songs in the cover
and we we we did that on the spot and
probably i just had the lyrics there
my boy [__] played the piano and just
sang it and the next thing we know it's
blowing up it's all over the internet it
was a great moment um
yes i i just i love uh you know
i love trying to reinterpret great songs
just to really enjoy that
when when did you realize that in your
life i've got a special voice like how
old were you were you young
um i don't know whether it's for me to
say i've got a special voice but
uh when were people reacting to it
i'll never forget we went uh
me and my my dad's side of the family
all my a lot of my family from glasgow
we all went down at the this pub in red
car where i'm from
called the crown and anchor
they had this [__] uh like karaoke
competition i was around easter time and
i got up and sang
everything i do i do it for you by brian
adams and
i remember the whole pub was just like
weeping and i won an easter egg and a
tenner
how old were you i was about 11 12
something like that
maybe maybe a bit younger and and i
think that was the first moment where i
knew like i was able to move
a bunch of people by singing because
people were jen
in the room which i i felt like i
genuinely moved everyone in there
and um and then like it was this thing i
was like sing everyone just sing all the
time and i would just you know become
like the performing monkey within the
family and stuff and
what did your dad say that when he was
in the pub after you just
like mopped the floor with everyone my
dad's my dad's always been so proud of
me and
he loves that i'm into music because
he's such a big music fan
i mean he brought like the sort of music
that he played to me it was really
important i think you know that real
like rock
music the real that music were really
integral that's the edge that
yeah voice cast like there's a do you
know bad company that's the band band
coming yeah i'll never forget my dad
playing me the song
bad company by bad company um
which is um i was just i can't remember
the name of the singer now
uh but i never forget i got i got um
excluded from school and he picked me up
from school he's like god you know we
shaped me
and i was like yeah and he put this song
on
and i'll never forget how it made me
feel and there's just this guy when he
started singing
and it became one of my favorite songs i
just i remember that being the moment
where i knew like this is what i want to
do
is i want to make music because this
song like has made me feel
like i'm in the right place at the right
time um as corny as that might sound but
i remember your dad crying on the
x-factor audition actually yeah it was
adorable actually yeah my dad yeah my
dad's uh he's
he's a he looks like a hard man your dad
you know so watch him
yeah he's like that there was you know
guys from glasgow are like
like they pride themselves on being
being hard so it's from partic like
oh yeah yeah he's [__] yeah yeah the
men are made of metal and the ships are
made of wood up there
yeah um
are you spiritual do you believe in god
or do you have any beliefs of that
nature do you know what that's
you've asked me that question at a time
when probably for the first time ever
i have really um
started to believe in and stuff like
that yeah um
i went through that phase of like the
whole zeitgeist thing and
you know like it's all bollocks it's all
commercial ripoff you know religion it
just does nothing but cause wars and
and all that kind of stuff but i don't
know
there was a point uh there's a point in
2020 where
it's a weird it's a weird way of
describing it i went through this sort
of cleanse where
i was just doing like aloe vera and
[__] water and
i remember being on this hike and just
being like um
just thinking about it just thinking
about how like having faith
um uh and believing in spirituality
um you know sometimes when you when
you're broken down or the to the core to
the bare bones and
and that's all you've got is you and and
your conscious and
or god whatever it may be um having that
faith
like you know you see some of the most
except some of the people that i look up
to the most
fighters you know they they get in the
ring and once they've won the fight they
give all the glory to god and they
believe truly believe that he had their
back that whole time in that fight
because i've been being close to giving
up on a few occasions
yeah for sure do you feel like you are
you've you've contemplated that with
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah it's well
documented i've
i've been quite open about it because i
just
i feel like people in our position have
a
responsibility to um be honest about
that sort of stuff
yeah because a lot of people feel that
way and we should normalize it and take
the stigma away and all that
i agree yeah i mean the last two years
for me in health the amount of times
i've thought about
suicide and it's like you know you think
why
why would i be thinking that like i've
got a lot that people would want to have
but it's like
you can't force yourself to be happy
yeah you know what i mean and then when
you're in those low parts and you just
think thinking
i want out here like i don't want to do
this anymore like you know and it would
just be easier
yeah you know what i mean but you're
right you know um
and it's a it's a real shame that
there's peop you know some people don't
have
what we have and uh i can't yeah
exactly imagine feeling like that and
then you know i'm saying this from a
position of
privilege yeah let alone you know me
ten years ago you know what i mean but
um
yeah it doesn't matter what happens in
your circumstances of life what's going
on in here
it sometimes it doesn't impact it
you know what i mean it you can be you
have all the money in the world you
could have everything like you see all
the success you've had and you've still
been there where you're thinking yeah i
don't want to do this anymore
um so yeah i credit you for being open
about that mate
um what's your biggest regret oh
there's two there's too many is there
any that stand out or
i don't i think i don't think i don't
think i pay any mind to them anymore
i'll be honest
i think good i don't i think i think i
got to the point where i had so many
regrets
um that it was just too much of a burden
to carry
probably and uh yeah
so now it's sort of like it's no regrets
i think but
definitely i know that i know they're
there but i don't pay any mind to them
do you think you look forward more than
backwards
yeah 100 i have to i've got to look
forward if i
i can't live in the past i think that's
where there was that's the real turning
point for me was that was
was um you know taking every day as it
comes
taking each day as it comes because i
was definitely like either
pre anticipating the future too much or
living in the past and
um i'm sure i'm sure you've had a lot of
people on here saying similar things to
to that you know that it's the most
common thing not really if i'm honest i
think that's a good take on it if
anything
i'll probably take a leaf out your book
because yeah are definitely
my depression definitely stems from
thinking of oh you [__] this up you
[__] that up you [__] the other up
yeah and then stressing about the future
and going
oh what if i don't do this good enough
what if this isn't perfect
i need to be better yeah and i think
it's really healthy to go
today live right now and what can i do i
would do
you have to yeah that's uh that's that's
the advice i would give anyone i mean
there's kind of like if we're talking
about mental health and anxiety and
i think my main pillars that i would
that i would give to
to anyone listening would be would be
that is
you can't look forward and you can't
look back um you gotta you gotta stay in
the moment because that's the only way
that you
you don't feel that anxiety and the
other one would be um
we talked we sort of touched on it
earlier i started reading um a lot of
work by this
um author called
rene brown brene brown she's called and
her whole thing is
vulnerability is courage basically where
you know
um we all see uh being vulnerable and
talking about our feelings and stuff and
um you know you you especially being a
big guy or you you know
we talked about that as well like you
know being vulnerable you can see it as
a weakness
um whereas you know nobody dislikes the
guy who walks in and goes i've had a
[__] [__] day man like i'm
my [__] girlfriend's on my case like
i've just been whatever dropped by my
record label whatever
like how can you dislike that guy and i
always stayed away from being that guy
and i pretended everything was all right
i was just
kind of like yeah i've got this going on
i've got that going on [__]
everything's great um when i stopped
being that guy and started being the guy
that was just like
i feel like [__] like
things just and then started taking
things day by day and realizing that it
takes a lot of courage to do that
and then because whenever i would do
that like just for example
just to just to maybe break it down even
better and not waffle on so much but
like i would go into a lot of studio
sessions a lot of writing sessions
and um and you have to make yourself
vulnerable in those situations because
otherwise you're not going to get
something authentic
musically you're just not going to get
good lyrics the vibe won't be right you
won't get anything that's going to
ultimately leave that room and move a
bunch of people
in the future it's not going to be a
good i don't believe you can you can
make
good music out of just formulas you know
formulaic [__] pop [__] like it's gotta
be real if it's gonna do something
forever to be fair a lot of the the pop
songs that we
enjoy that are sung by these little pop
artists they're actually written by
someone feeling
someone who's feeling someone's actually
good has written that absolutely
it's just it's gone through the machine
it's gone through that [__] yeah and
it's been what you know what
what down or whatever and so i used to
be in them situations and like
i knew i had to wear my heart on my
sleeve i knew i had to be vulnerable and
i knew it's like a therapy session
songwriting sessions you know it always
is and you're doing it with people you
barely know
a lot of the times a bit like you know
we've met each other for the first time
in person today and we've talked about a
lot of really personal [__] here
yeah and it's uncomfortable at times and
it gives you anxiety at times
and you and you sit here and you like
grapple with shame you're like oh
they're ashamed of that bit you know i
mean
i would do that i would leave them
sessions and i would spend the whole
night
feeling shame like oh they must think
i'm a [__] [__] i must think i'm
like
weirdo or i'm shame as a killer actually
and it's a killer and it's a killer
um and then and then i think changing
that mindset and and
listening to this this amazing woman
talk about those things like
um like it's all that feel the fear and
do it anyway
all that stuff you know like um what's
that saying that she that she says about
like um like
not being putting yourself in the arena
and not being you're not being scared to
fail you know we're gonna [__] up
there's no doubt about that you know but
at least you put yourself in there
and that showed courage and that's
something to be proud of
yeah i've adopted that in the last
couple of years you started stripping
back and just going
like he has made [__] no
apologies yeah like
as every year has gone by with my
youtube the less it's been about
here's what you expect from me and the
more it's been about who i actually am
and that's why i think i really i really
relate to you and i love listening to
your talk and i love i love your
podcasts and
because you're just a real that's you're
a real person and you're human
and people look you know it's great
we're in perfect paul
exactly you know what i mean exactly um
all right we've got two questions after
um
if your life was a movie and
you know you get the middle part of the
movie the bit where everything sort of
changes
yeah what do you think that moment would
be i guess for you it may be an obvious
one a lot of people would expect
the x factor audition would you say that
would be the one yeah
but i would put i would probably say the
probably the moment where i wrote that
song
because that that really that
that trumped everything you know all the
odds
that [__] little three and a half
minute song
that i sat down and wrote brought me
back from the dead like
really did back from the edge back from
the edge yeah and
i was just wondering you know because
obviously as
as i've felt before you don't know how
many people are jealous of you
until they're all kicking you when
you're down that's when you start
writing oh you
oh you're a [__] you are yeah yeah um
and
and when they think oh you're gone
you're [__] you're never coming back
that's when everyone piles onto you
and that happened to you and i know how
that feels
what was it like on the way about
popcorn like did you
did you take any make any mental notes
of those people did you have any moments
like that where you got to say your
piece to the yeah
i'd be lying if i said it didn't take a
little bit of restraint not to be like
ah so you want to oh so you want to
resign me okay
like you know i mean like
it was never about my numbers or
anything like that
you know when i say numbers i mean
albums sold and
things like that you know psycho
notoriously dropped every one that they
ever
signed all due respect to psycho i know
they're trying to
they were trying to run a record label
but they'd got this reputation for like
cutthroat
they were pretty cutthroat if you didn't
if they did if you didn't have that big
hit if you didn't keep it going
it's it's back to obscurity for you sort
of thing there's
there's not a lot of artists development
going on there if you like um
and i think they they they were a bit
reactionary in dropping me
um and they maybe kind of nurtured the
situation a bit better
i hope you're negotiating hard bro yeah
you know when they
when they came back in i mean they're no
longer a label now they just went into
liquidation and i just signed a really
i'm
a very proud moment i signed a deal with
columbia uk where a
really proper label prestigious label of
you know people like bob dylan signed
there and stuff which is which was huge
for me
but yeah when you know when they came
back and they were very humble to be
fair they came they were like you know
we [__] up with
because we they got the option to sign
me back weeks prior
before the single did what it did and
they
were like nah we don't we're not gonna
so
they had to swallow it big time when
they when they called me up i remember
obviously now you know i was a fan the
whole time yeah and i
i'm the type of person i like being
right so you know when you call somebody
and you're like
like a fighter is going to win the title
yeah when i first seen you
on the first audition i was like this
this might this sorry sound like
[__] because you sat in front of us
but i'm
[__] genuinely saying that's the
winner right there
i'm telling you now he's relatable he's
got talent and he's just done something
with the song we haven't seen before i'm
telling you you know he's gonna [__]
win
when you won it i was like yeah [__]
yeah yeah yeah so then when it all went
tits
i was like [__] like i actually um
you know not that i was heavily invested
in the situation but i was like i
thought this kid was the
was the exception to the rule yeah and
then when it happened to you as well i
mean
[__] it out i didn't think that would
happen but then when you came back i was
like that was right
yeah yeah yeah i was happy for you i
like that
um you know it's great it's great to
hear that
all you proved the cream rises to the
top so you should be proud of that i'm
very proud and i appreciate you saying
that and you know that's what keeps me
going to be fair because if i
if i've made songs like in the past like
i made something called empty space and
i thought
this is [__] banging it's class this
is this should be number one like why
isn't it that's one of my favorite songs
you've made
i mean i i like it didn't do what i
thought it was gonna do
shocking really and i was like right
okay back to the drawing board then just
to be clear it still did [__] great
fantastic you have the standards now
yeah like still
in in the hundred millions of streams on
spotify and like people are like what
you want about what i'm like
yeah but that's that was a number one
single in my head
and that's why i think that sometimes
like maybe he's have that like
irrational gripe with the industry where
i'm like
hang on a minute is it because of you
because you didn't [__] play it
enough or whatever and
maybe that's you know that's something i
need uh you know um
but having said that it means that i'll
keep
trying to better that and like you love
that song i'm gonna make you a song that
you love even more and
that's you know that that that does
motivate me so
it's probably a good thing and i think
it's a long way to go in my career a
long way to go in my journey and
um i'm really excited i'm excited to
i think this i've got a single coming
out next friday and i think
that's a number one single i'm going to
say what is the day at the singles out
5th of march
okay um i don't know whether this would
be out before or after well they know
now
it's out it will be over the fifth of
march and it's it's
i think it's if that doesn't do well
maybe i'll think about wrapping it up
um last question yeah how would you like
to be remembered
and maybe he's like to be put in that
category with someone who
who maybe didn't who maybe wasn't
perfect this might be a bit of a
maybe a bit like polarizing sense some
people love me and some people
hate me but um you can't deny my
um what my music can do in the future
i'll help you with social media all
right
yes please yes please mate no no
it's been a great chat me i've
thoroughly enjoyed this me too i really
appreciate it
and good luck with the [__] album i'm
sure it's going to be class coming out
later this year yes sir yeah single out
fifth of march better march yeah album
later on
and that is james arthur on the true
jordan youtube channel appreciate you
thanks for having me
um hit the like button subscribe and
i'll see you guys later cheers everyone
quality thank you for having me
that's a good stint that's a good step
you know i almost had a good chuck
because most people
i do them about hour i did fury an hour
and 20 minutes do people start like
wavering normally i'm just
i was interested in you
thank yeah so much